[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best show well because my
brothers and i said it was and that's
how the internet works
this is the show that we wish that we
had when we were learning about business
investing in finance uh i'm laughing
because we have a special guest for you
guys today but before we get to that my
brothers are here joe and john how do
you know their names are joe and john
real simple their names are on the back
of their chairs uh bill pulte is here
for the full two hours there he is for
those of you that don't know at polti on
twitter uh how many followers you have
now on twitter and instagram i've i
think 2.7 on twitter 2.7 million and
then on instagram i think it's 1.6 or
1.7 so he's got like 20 million
followers on social media
2.8 don't understand yourself bill bill
doesn't know this but if you move your
head your name is on the back of the
chair as well
sweet
everyone knows where to sit when they
come on the show no problem at all all
right so bill is here for full two hours
here's how this is gonna work we're
gonna do with normal show
bill is going to spend time walking us
through his thoughts on various topics
and then after we get done with that
we're gonna spend the last hour uh
talking to bill about his life about
twitter philanthropy in the last 30
minutes we are going to take questions
from the audience so if you stick around
the last 30 minutes of the show you'll
get to ask bill whatever you want john
and joe will pick all the questions the
crazier the question probably the more
likely it is that you get picked and i
also promised that i'd give away a
thousand dollars so let me go
listening to this if bill gives away a
thousand dollars if bill gives away a
thousand dollars i'll match the thousand
wow oh 2 000
don't be looking at me
i thought we were going to just kind of
we're not going down the line here we're
going to just rack up the amount there
all right so we'll give away some money
i'll give away this hat
i got it for the end of the show uh
sofi dot com slash pomp make sure that
you go there check them out you can buy
ten dollars of bitcoin and you get ten
dollars for free it's the only place on
the internet that i think you can get
buy one get one for bitcoin so go to
sofi.com
check it out all right second of all
is the merch first bill was kind enough
bill brought me this look at this
there's twitter philanthropy right here
you don't have one but i got one bill's
wearing one right here pretty damn dope
and my favorite no charge for those of
you that uh
look got a nice little american flag
there too so this is not for sale but
breaking news
we
have in the store they're back we don't
have a lot of them but not only do we
have the trillionaire energy hoodies
like this there's also a new design that
we have that i think we're going to pull
up here where you can go into the store
there it is right there
two separate
different designs for the trillionaire
energy hoodies you can go to
bestbusiness show.com trillionaire go
pick them up that's what it's all about
all right let's jump into it there's
absolute madness going on in the world
of finance business uh and investing
first yesterday janet yellen treasury
secretary said that unrealized capital
gains are income and when you think
about unrealized capital gains the
reaction in the business and investing
community is exactly what you would
expect people can't possibly believe
anyone who understands economics would
actually say that unrealized capital
gains are income an unrealized gain from
a definition standpoint is an increase
in the value of an asset or an
investment that an investor holds but
has not yet sold for cash such as an
open stock position so if i go ahead and
i buy let's say a hundred dollars worth
of a stock and that stock doubles in
price my hundred dollars turns into two
hundred dollars unrealized gain is a
hundred dollars right the the amount of
the profit that i would have if i was to
sell what we are talking about here is
the idea that you will be taxed on the
gain of an investment that also is not
just about
your investments in terms of the stock
market also could be applied to things
like your home if you buy a home for
let's say a hundred thousand dollars and
now all of a sudden it's worth 150 000
you have a 50 000 unrealized gain on
your home and therefore you could be
taxed which means that if you don't have
enough cash to pay the tax you may have
to actually sell the home in order to
get the money to then pay for the
tax pretty insane stuff here so we've
got this tweet from uh john
told or brad houston i actually don't
know what his real name is because he's
got a different name at the handle and a
different name for the twitter profile
but john or brad said yellen just said
that unrealized capital gains his income
let that sink in unrealized gains is
income pretty absurd we then have the
definition of unrealized gains
in terms of these key takeaways it's
real simple it's an increase in the
value of an asset or an investment that
you hold but have not yet sold for cash
unrealized loss is a decrease in the
value of an asset or investment even
though you haven't sold it yet so it's
an open position but you either get a
gain or a loss and then if we go on here
is how this works we've got at
documenting fiat which is a pretty
good twitter handle says scam alert
unrealized capital gains tax one they
print a ton of money which results in
them stealing purchasing power two asset
prices go up and the money goes down and
then they essentially tax the assets
because they say that they've gone up
too much in price they will milk you dry
nowhere is safe but
on top of this we shouldn't really
expect anything different remember this
is the same government that currently
has a 3.5 trillion dollar infrastructure
bill that is
2500 pages long look at this picture
this is an absurd photo we have this guy
holding this is their bill
2
500 pages
if you take a look at 3.5 trillion
dollar price tag
and you do the math that's 1 billion 400
million dollars
for every page
of this bill
that's right there is one billion four
hundred million dollars of spending on
every single page of that spending bill
holding it together with twine
it is so big that he literally had to
put a rope around the pages to keep them
together and then they tied it with a
nice little price tag like they were on
the price is right or at a dollar
discount store
but
if you thought that was crazy here is
the last and final one jen pasake i
believe how you say her name who is
basically the spokesperson she's just up
there answering questions from the media
recently had this comment to say about
the idea that companies may increase
their prices if taxes increase
she essentially said that it is unfair
and absurd we're gonna play the video
for you here in a second that the
companies would pass their tax increases
over to the consumer in the form of
higher prices that's right there is a
belief that in the current
administration we are going to have
taxes go up cost of goods go up but the
companies should not raise their prices
and they should just make less money
which is exactly the opposite they say
according to if i've read the chart
correctly
more than 16 of taxpayers would see
their taxes increase under the the bill
that's approved by the house ways and
means committee will the president sign
that bill
if as it is coming out of that committee
or will he insist on the changes so that
he will maintain his commitment that
taxes won't go up on people making 400
000 a year i have not looked at the uh
document or the report that you have put
out obviously the president or that you
have referenced i should say that the
republicans put out uh obviously the
president's commitment remains not
raising taxes for anyone making less
than 400 000 a year there are some and
i'm not sure if this is the case in this
report who argue that in the past
companies have passed on these costs to
consumers i'm not sure if that's the
argument being made in this report
we feel that that's unfair and absurd
and the american people would not stand
for that but i will take a closer look
at this report and get you a more
substantive response go ahead jackie
that's right
companies are not going to raise any of
their prices and there's gonna be
taxes on unrealized gains so first let's
start with joe and john what do you guys
think about the idea of them taxing the
un unrealized capital gains i mean it's
such a wild idea outlandish idea that
it's hard to believe anyone would
actually take that seriously right like
there's no chance this actually pas
passes uh i'd put it very very very very
close to zero percent uh but just the
idea and the thought process behind
taxing unrealized capital gains like it
just makes no sense right like you
people wouldn't even be able to afford
uh the tax bill at the end of the year
given kind of whatever percentage they
have in unrealized gains it just makes
no sense from a monetary standpoint
yeah it's gonna force people to sell
force more people to hold the dollar
it's
frankly a dumb idea
but um
look i don't even know why they said it
bill what do you think do you think it's
even going to happen i think there is a
next to zero percent chance it just
happens it's ridiculous it's not even
worth talking about right i mean the
problem is that this is what they want
right they want us talking about this
they want us you know arguing about who
should pay more taxes and all this kind
of stuff it's ridiculous the part that i
think is hilarious uh is one
you can't build financial security if
every year you literally pay 30 40 50
it's all short-term uh capital gains
right so it's all income tax uh
and even if the stock market goes up 30
a year and just hold the s p and they're
literally taking 40 to 50 of it every
single year of your gains you break
compounding which is the first rule you
know violation of rules of finance but
on top of that what becomes even crazier
to me is you just completely discourage
the investment well will they pay
unrealized losses
this is this is the best the other
argument is are you going to give people
the unrealized losses because by the way
if i just hold cash i lost money right
do i get do i essentially get a credit
for the the losses i don't think so no
and everybody would depreciate
everything right
and then you'd get just tons of losses
and then the government would be
spending even more money than they
already are
my feeling is the math doesn't work yeah
my feeling is that they would have to
carve out some assets to not allow it to
be included so for example uh i can't
imagine they would say to an everyday
average american that makes you know 50
60 000 a year hey we're gonna tax you on
your unrealized gains of your home
right like that would be just peak
insanity
but i also thought that them to even
talking about unrealized capital gains
was gonna be you know pretty insane and
here we are so i i i don't know uh but
when you start looking at they're
spending 3.5 trillion in their opinion
they have to get the money from
somewhere right and so what do you do
you say hey we're just going to tax the
people who have all the gains and the
bottom 45 percent of americans hold no
investments so they're not worried about
it right because they don't they're
unaffected uh but the problem is if you
tax all the businesses you tackle tax
all the individuals holding the
investment assets what do they do they
drive prices up right it actually is the
kind of reverse effect that you want
yeah well it affects kind of the people
that are less economically um
sound more right by the increases in
prices on all goods the fact that she
said the american people will not stand
for this is if this happens they won't
really have a choice the price will just
be the price of when they go to the
store the chipotle prices are way too
damn high and they're not coming down
right what did chipotle do they did i
think three or four percent gain uh
increase in menu prices earlier this
year tyson foods was up seven percent in
q1 like we've documented all these price
increases and nobody's gonna bring them
back down nobody's gonna pay their
employees less money uh and on top of
that they're going to continue to
increase if you listen to all the
earnings calls all these publicly traded
ceos are like we increased prices
actually we were very surprised
pleasantly by the adoption of our
customer base they didn't seem to mind
right we're going to continue to do this
moving forward and so it's like hey we
tested this oh customers didn't care
like we're just going to keep increasing
the prices over time and uh and no one's
going to stop us yeah i mean it's
for-profit business it's kind of like uh
shocking and alarming that we have
people in positions of power uh that are
at least even willing to say that kind
of stuff right like it just makes no
sense do we worry about the unfair
terminology like it where it becomes a
game of fairness not a game of
competition yeah they want you to feel
like you're morally or ethically doing
something wrong for increasing your
prices to make a living for your
business
yeah the whole idea of just like hey by
the way joe's going to sell me a good
that i'm going to turn around he's going
to sell me wood let's say for example
and i'm going to go build something i'm
going to sell a table right joe
increases his prices 20 so i'm supposed
to be uh fair and not increase my prices
20 so that i can keep the same margin it
makes no sense
i agree
look they already uh small businesses
were already devastated throughout the
pandemic and told to in most cases that
they couldn't go to work they couldn't
open they couldn't do their kind of
normal business activities and now
you're telling them that it's unethical
or or
morally incorrect to raise prices to
account for supply chain issues or all
these other things doesn't make much
sense i agree all right we're uh we're
about 15 minutes in i think that we
should figure out how are we gonna pick
people to give money to today
i don't know maybe i do my first
thousand and then you do your thousand i
can go through the i'm gonna do more
than a thousand i decided really yeah
well john's gonna do a thousand too
i'll do a thousand too
how are we going to pick people um
just go on youtube comments all right if
you go in the youtube comments in five
minutes we'll come up with a question
we'll ask the question anyone who's
watching a comment and then we'll go
ahead and we'll pick somebody uh to be
the uh the winner so far we have three
thousand dollars being given away today
maybe there will be at least 4 000
because joe will stop being a cheapskate
yeah i have somebody going in right now
and finding somebody and sending one
thousand dollars to somebody so once i
have that i'll post it oh all right so
so right now you're already picking some
yeah my team's doing so if you're if
you're if you're on youtube bill
literally just he shoots at tech stuff
he's like hey we're gonna give away a
thousand dollars we're over here looking
through the comments trying to pick
people like tell us john's like
following me on twitter or not
i say helping people is an expensive
sport exactly all right so if you're in
the comments right now and you want to
potentially be picked make sure that you
leave a comment uh tell us your story
tell us what's going on so that we can
go ahead and uh or bill's team will go
ahead and try to pick somebody uh to
give the first thousand dollars to all
right next story is we've got el
salvador uh the president of el salvador
as many people know uh buchelli has been
talking about uh mining bitcoin with
volcano energy which just sounds awesome
uh and so when we first said this
everyone uh we were in this twitter
space and he was like oh yeah we were
looking at mining bitcoin with volcano
energy i think everyone kind of was like
is he serious like what is volcano
energy and then all of a sudden he
started to explain it and when he
started to explain the volcano energy we
realized he is dead serious and so
yesterday he posted this brand new video
of the progress report on actually
mining bitcoin using volcano energy in
el salvador so let's start with the
video first and then we'll talk about
what this actually means for bitcoin
bitcoin mining in the country
this is a dope video
[Music]
i mean pretty damn cool right when you
start to see that they're actually
mining
uh bitcoin with that volcano energy and
so as we look to this the whole idea of
bitcoin as a tool for el salvador one
they are trying to attract investment
they're trying to attract people to move
to the country who align with the values
of that uh political regime or with that
country's kind of stance on bitcoin two
is they're trying to improve the economy
of el salvador we've talked at nauseam
about the fact that 70 80 of the
population has no bank account
remittance make up 20 to 50 percent of
gdp uh it's extremely expensive and so
can they get that economy boosted by
adopting bitcoin as legal tender and
then lastly is they want to minimize the
commissions for sending remittances so
when el salvador first came out and said
that they were going to do all this
there's a ton of critics who said i
don't think that they're being serious i
don't think they're actually going to
execute on this is just another
politician looking for campaign points
we now have the video of them actually
building the ability to mine bitcoin
using volcano energy but we also had
another tweet from the president of el
salvador that explicitly states 2.1
million salvadorians are actively using
the chivo wallet not downloads chivo is
not a bank but in less than three weeks
it has now more users than any bank in
el salvador and is moving fast to have
more users that all banks in el salvador
combined this is wild he also included
another tweet the actual dashboard for
chiva what president anywhere in the
world is tweeting out dashboards to the
technology that the country created not
many so there you can see i don't speak
spanish but i can read numbers and you
can see that they've got about 2.2
million
users totales uh which is uh i think
translated to total and then also you
can see how many new users per minute
are signing up uh this would be a hot
silicon valley series a company right if
you showed up to an investor's office
and you said here's our dashboard here's
our numbers look how fast we're growing
there's a lot of people who'd be super
interested in funding your idea so what
do we think about uh bitcoin in el
salvador in terms of them both doing the
volcano energy mining and also the
adoption so far the chiva wallet how
does this volcano energy mining work
right like
that that's the facility i guess that
they're doing this on are they actively
already doing it in what terms like are
they already mining bitcoin with that
that how do they already get this
facility set up so quickly well they
already had the energy production
facility near the uh volcano so when
they first went and uh he talked about
this they already had a lot of that
infrastructure in place and that's why
he was thinking about what do we do with
the energy that's coming out of this and
i actually think this is the second site
that they've looked at because there was
another video of a different site that
they were actually looking at and so if
you already have the ability to produce
the energy then it's all about just
where do you put it so if you have
geothermal or volcano energy right then
all of a sudden what can you do you can
say hey i can send it to the grid and i
can go power homes i can send it to some
sort of commercial facility i can use it
for government purposes or i can just
keep it right there on site and i can
mine bitcoin and what they're
essentially doing is they're
capitalizing on the fact that they got
infrastructure they got access to the
power so why don't we go ahead and just
mine bitcoin as well the interesting
part for the chivo is it's basically a
third of the country right they have
just over six million people and they
have 2.1 actively using the chivo wall
which i think is really important um and
we're going to get to later on the show
when we talk about
twitter and subscribe the integration
they use with bitcoin as well but the
remittance fees are a lot lower using
chivo i think it's it's great for the
country and great for bitcoin but they
also didn't give i know there was like
some incentive what was it thirty
dollars
yeah so it's really not a crazy amount
relative to kind of the the median wage
there for monthly yeah it might seem uh
significant but look it's obviously
working they have two points
2.1 million people actively using the
wallet so there's a lot of technology
companies that pay wait spend way
exactly that's more
point right so it's clearly helped with
the adoption phase uh and we'll see like
it looks like they're gonna go a lot
more than that it's only been three four
weeks is the president of el salvador
the ceo of the hottest tech company in
south america right now
yeah i mean look i mean who else goes
from creation to two plus million users
in a month he could raise money at
whatever he wanted that's bitcoin right
yeah
it's bitcoin of course what do you think
about bitcoin i think bitcoin is the
best
by the way we have 4 600 people in here
right now
and we got 1.7 000 likes so i will have
a name here in about one second that
we're giving away the money too perfect
so one of the ideas around the chiva
wallet we're waiting for bill to do that
is uh when you go ahead and you say to
people i'm going to give you lower
commissions on remittances i'm also
going to pay you 30 to adopt it and i've
also built infrastructure in terms of
the atms both the united states and in
el salvador you're essentially reducing
the friction for people to integrate or
interface with this network and it would
be one thing if people were just
downloading the app getting their thirty
dollars and then moving on but the fact
that they're active users people are
coming back and using it over and over
and over again and if that retention
holds this ends up being one of the most
important uh technologies in south
america right now and it wouldn't be
surprising to see other countries
starting to try to figure out how they
can go ahead uh and adopt it as well
right yeah i'm curious if we see other
countries try to adopt this by the end
of the year i think that's going to be a
really big curve seeing the adoption
that el salvador has seen uh but we'll
see going into the end of the year i
think definitely next year at a minimum
we're going to see other countries kind
of using the same strategy that el
salvador how much uh bitcoin did they
are buying like 150 or 200 million devin
bought it all yet i think they've bought
like maybe 400 bitcoin or so uh which
you know 20 25 million bitcoin whatever
uh but um their goal is to get to like
150 million and uh when the president is
tweeting that they're buying the dip i
think they're gonna get there pretty
quick yeah i mean 30 of the country
already has actively using the chiva
wallet i think what we're going to see
is they're going to wish that they
bought it quicker quicker and uh more
aggressively right and like it's a
smaller country but go back to your
point from yesterday of like the us has
the opportunity especially with china uh
you know banning it in and saying it's
illegal for the tenth time it seems uh
the u.s has the opportunity to really
aggressively uh start to invest and use
it and say hey look we could put
point five percent one percent of our
national budget uh and just buy a [ __ ]
on a bitcoin right and uh i think el
salvador's gonna wish that they had more
i agree all right we have the winner of
the first thousand dollar giveaway here
bill who is it and i apologize for
butchering this name
uh meluska mendoza melusa maluska
mendoza a thousand bucks already sent
look at that you watched the show
and you got a chance to win money do we
what you're gonna be doing another
thousand right oh we're gonna do a lot
more you're going to do it every 30
years
so there's for every thousand people
that watch
concurrently i'll give away another
thousand wow
how about that
let's go
invite your friends and watch the show
bill you haven't been here before
there's only one thing that joe likes
more than bitcoin is giving away my
money
i think i wasn't like that too i wasn't
here
it seems pretty fun i wasn't here for an
episode
and joe literally was just like hey
we're giving away all his money
so it's fine all right so where are we
at right now we're at 4 700 people uh
around 11 30 or so we'll give away the
next thousand dollars but for every
thousand people we get in here i'll go
ahead and i'll give away another
thousand bucks we'll see how uh how
broke i end up being by the end of the
show um all right speaking of bitcoin
twitter and sub stack have both launched
bitcoin tipping or the ability to
integrate the bitcoin network into their
services obviously twitter came out with
this idea of bitcoin uh tipping is what
most people are referring it to but what
you can actually do is not only can you
send bitcoin but you can send dollars
across the bitcoin network leveraging
strike in their technology uh when you
think about twitter they are one of the
largest social media companies in the
world and now anyone who has this
functionality enabled you're able to
send and receive dollars to anyone else
in the world simply using their twitter
account if i meet john on twitter i
don't have to say hey what's your venmo
or your cash app or your other name i
can simply send him money now right
through twitter pretty damn cool and
then if you look at somebody like sub
stack substack has officially integrated
bitcoin tipping as well uh through a
payment service with a partnership of
opennode and the idea here is everyone
expected twitter to do something jack
dorsey obviously is a very big proponent
of twitter but substack was an
interesting move most people didn't know
that they were so into bitcoin and so
they said quote is the product designer
at subsets saying quote we're excited to
be working with opennode to enable
independent publishers on subsec to
accept crypto payments having this
option will give writers more
flexibility and freedom and we look
forward to doing more in crypto to meet
writer's needs now of course the idea of
flexibility and freedom aligns
drastically with the bitcoin ethos
that's the whole point of bitcoin and so
while this isn't completely
decentralized this isn't something where
there's full sovereignty it does provide
for more people getting access to this
network being able to use a superior
payment system whether you're on twitter
substack or you simply want to do
peer-to-peer transactions it's al it's
all now possible joe do you have uh
the tipping feature yet on twitter
you're asking me this because you know
that i don't and you know a butt hurt
about it well listen if you're gonna try
to give away my money you go and catch
some [ __ ] all right john do you have do
you have it i do not i i have to set
mine up all right bill i do oh
and i don't understand why people give
me money it's kind of one of these weird
things i mean i give away money and i
say you know you don't need to send me
money that's for sure but if you're
going to help somebody help somebody on
my feed or if you do send it to me i try
to put it to the highest and best use
yeah so what i'm doing is uh all of the
tips that i've gotten which actually is
starting to become like scary big number
uh given what i thought it was going to
be can you share like
certain amounts yeah let me see what uh
what it is well i'm giving all of my i'm
going to set mine up why don't we test
it out with you sending me something i'm
going to give all because because rather
than send it to you i'm going to send
all of the money people are sending me
to the human rights foundation oh what
about but
[Applause]
uh
292.59 uh that's been sent to me in the
last like three days yeah that's insane
so i appreciate it's 250 you wouldn't
have otherwise had yeah and now i'm to
turn around i'm going to give it to
human rights foundation and they can go
give it a bitcoin developers they can
give to people that matter and like 290
isn't going to change the world right
but it's the idea that uh anyone could
send that to me there's people who are
sending it to me from all over the world
who literally uh
uh already i'm scared to say this but
marketers have figured it actually no i
will say this because uh it just means
that i'm gonna tax you for uh abusing it
uh they send a dollar and then they put
a message and because it's on twitter
they know i'm gonna see it yeah and so
they're literally sending me things like
hey man uh just wanted to send you a
message by the way check out my deck or
hey by the way go check out my website
yeah right so fine that's fine you want
to send me the message if you send me uh
at least five dollars on twitter i will
look at whatever you send me but i'm
gonna take the money i'm gonna donate it
so really you're just donating the money
appreciate you uh for doing it it seems
like these tools are where the world's
going right the ability for anyone in
the world to send it like if you have
venmo i have cash app you've got paypal
and you are on zell
right yeah which is the legacy stuff uh
the the four of us can't actually send
money to each other right which is like
kind of absurd that there's not just one
integrated system that everyone can
transact with everybody else yeah it was
almost like when we communicated with
people just over the phone like you
remember in the early 2000s you guys are
a little bit younger but uh and you got
your first iphone and stuff like that it
just it almost feels like when you first
got your iphone and you start to feel
liberated and you could text message
people boom right there you know what i
mean and and this thing i mean you know
i'm big on the whole philanthropy
poverty angle and human rights
foundation is doing a great job with
this but this is just like a cancer that
in a good way that's going to just
spread everywhere i think because if
somebody has like a a kidney problem or
they're dying of cancer and they can't
afford groceries or they can't afford
insulin for their diabetes pump i mean
twitter is just going to unleash the
ability for people to instantaneously
get that to people without having to ask
them for information and everything so i
think that's one of the unintended
consequences outside of general commerce
that is not yet fully appreciated and
we've seen it in the past i mean maybe
you can tell one of the stories in terms
of i know a couple of times somebody has
reached out to you and said hey
so-and-so needs help and basically you
take that message and you turn around
and you say to your followers look i'm
going to give some money but like i need
your guys help so like how does that
work normally well a few weeks ago you
know you had the afghanistan situation
where the one of the soldiers well many
of them but one of them got killed and
their family was raising a gofundme and
i put out a tweet and boom within like
five minutes it was
if the thing was climbing and we raised
i think we helped raise over twenty
thousand dollars for that person now i
only put in two hundred dollars into
that one in particular because i say
that i'm just one millionaire i'm just
one person and if i help people that's
amazing and that's great and i don't
want to discourage anybody but to me
twitter philanthropy and what we're
doing will not be successful so long as
it is dependent on me and so that's why
i'm trying to raise and inspire other
people to give and what twitter has done
is just unlock that key to that whole
door and and i think just i think the
floodgates are going to be
it's pretty crazy unleashed right it
really is crazy and i think that there's
another element of this as well where
you see people um
who uh they really do need help right
obviously everyone always worries
there's you know scams or whatever but
for the most part most of these people
are good intention they need help uh and
technology has empowered them now to not
only get the message out but also for
people to be able to help right even if
you knew in the past hey somebody across
town i read in the newspaper needs help
you'd have to go track them down get
their bank information whatever now not
so much right now it's a much better how
do you know that there's not scams and
charities i mean you read all the time
about all the bloat and waste and you
know some of these charities and stuff
so i say look if 90 of the people are
legitimately in need which by the way
you know anecdotally my experience has
been 90 are true because very rarely is
somebody going to fake cancer or fake
that they need an insulin pump i mean
that happens but that's the minority so
if i have 90 or good and 10 are bad i'll
take those odds all day long absolutely
uh before we get into uh talking about
home price growth uh which i know you
know a ton about so i'm really excited
to talk to you about it we're gonna give
away another thousand dollars right now
i would say that we're gonna pick from
the chat i don't know if this is gonna
be possible uh but maybe if you're
watching right now here's how we're
gonna do this uh i want you to leave a
comment in the chat and tell us what is
the nicest thing that you've done for
somebody this year in 2021 that's good
so go ahead and leave a comment right
now uh what is the nicest thing that
you've done for somebody in 2021 john is
going to be responsible for trying to
pick who this person is about to win a
thousand dollars right now uh no
pressure
so very quickly let's get what's the
nicest thing that you've done for
somebody in 2021 whoever john picks a
thousand bucks coming your way right now
let's see what are some of these that
people are saying
to make my mom's home livable again
people want money because they want to
buy bitcoin they want to pay some of
their rent
provide grocery delivery to covet
positive households all right uh what do
you got for us john cassie wampler said
i gave my old car to a single mom
cassie how do i spell it k-a-s-e-y
k-a-s-e-y wampler
you win a thousand bucks what did they
do
i gave my old card to a single mom
awesome all right cassie we just i just
tagged you in the chat so you know that
that's exactly who it is if you can dm
john on twitter and john's going to make
sure that uh we get your information and
we're going to get you the thousand
bucks hopefully before the show is over
uh but if not then we'll do it right
after the show so cassie congratulations
thank you for being so kind to people uh
and uh where are we at we're at about
four thousand people in here right now
we've already given away two thousand
john's giving away a thousand he's ready
to rock and roll we'll do that in a few
minutes but uh in terms of home price
growth
it feels good what do you need all that
money for yeah oh trust me i
there's uh uh
earlier this year there was uh or i
guess at the end of last year into this
year there was the bar stool fund and
they basically raised much money for
small businesses and i think what was so
interesting about it to me is uh there's
a ton of people who realize oh wow i
don't have to just go donate to people
who live in some far off country or land
there's actually people who just right
down the street need help yeah right and
so i think that something that you've
really pioneered is uh there's people in
our communities right that need help and
so being able to help them is a pretty
cool thing yeah what he did was amazing
so insane i think he was second he got
second in the twitter philanthropy award
[Applause]
mr mr beast won mr beast one all right
all right so uh home price growth has
continued to climb to a new record in
july numbers are just in july was the
fourth consecutive month of record price
appreciation and it marked the highest
annual rate of price growth since the
end index began in 1987.
absolutely nuts the median existing home
sales price in august of this year rose
fourteen point nine percent from a year
earlier to three hundred and fifty six
thousand seven hundred dollars that's
right there's a fifteen percent increase
in the median existing home sales price
in america households that bought homes
in may are spending almost 21
of their income on monthly mortgage
payments which is above the average rate
for the past decade and we've got a
couple of charts here that we're going
to show the first is the july home price
growth surges
this is a absolutely nuts chart this
chart is showing that the year-over-year
change in july of 2021 was nearly 20
home prices up from the year before
pretty nuts the second one is while
price growth varies all metro areas are
up double digits so it doesn't matter
where you live if you live in a metro in
the united states home prices are up in
phoenix over 30 percent year over year
san diego over 25 percent if you look at
somewhere like las vegas or miami over
20 percent and still even places like
washington minneapolis and chicago up
over 10 or 15 percent absolutely nuts
and then if you look at this last chart
that we have the u.s home prices are 44
above their prior peak and so when you
look at this specifically we had the
prior pre uh peak during the housing
crisis everyone thought wow this is
super overvalued we never should see
these levels in home prices but today
currently we are 44 higher than we were
right during that housing crisis that is
the u.s on a blended basis in a place
like denver the home prices are double
what they were during the housing crisis
dallas seattle portland and charlotte
all over 50
as well and so bill help us understand
why exactly uh home prices are exploding
like this because it's actually a pretty
complex situation in terms of why
they're going up so much but what's kind
of your read on this well i think you
have to get back to basics right so
supply and demand everybody knows about
supply and demand let's look at demand
for a second you have a situation where
covet happened and literally the federal
government came in and started buying
mortgage-backed securities if the
federal government hadn't bought the
mortgage-backed securities you'd have a
real problem uh because liquidity would
dry up in the mortgage bond market and
the mortgage bond market is actually
what creates a lot of liquidity in
you know in the mortgage industry so you
have this incredible fuel for demand
which is you have the federal government
buying mortgage-backed securities you
have low interest rates which were
reduced even further in covit so on the
demand side of things you just have
gasoline on the fire and then on the
supply side you have the situation where
kovid created i would argue potentially
the biggest supply issue that the
industry's ever seen in the form of you
know starting stopping you have the
lumber prices going up and and all this
stuff so if you look at the demand and
you look at the supply it's just
creating an environment pump where you
know the prices just have gotten
unbelievable levels now the interesting
thing will be what happens in you know
as we get into 2022 halfway through
toward the end toward the end of 2022
will some capacity come back online so
you're able to get that supply up if you
can get the supply back up what can
happen is you can start to see some
moderating in the prices but for now
those two things affecting the supply
and demand as i described
are just creating an environment where
you know
good luck keeping it it's like keeping a
beach ball underwater help us understand
like the supply chain disruptions right
in terms of uh i think most people are
like oh i know that there's low interest
rates i kind of sort of know that people
are looking for homes so the demand side
they can wrap their head around but the
supply chain i just they don't see that
every day right it's like what do you
understand is going on well it's in part
caused by the demand side so i don't
want to say oh it's just all supply it's
also the fact as i said that the federal
government and most people don't talk
about this i think it will actually
happen in future elections
but people don't talk about it right now
the federal government has essentially
gone in and bought large portions of the
mortgage bond market that's a that's a
huge issue so i don't want to i don't
want to dismiss that in terms of supply
issues you know when covet happened i
think that naturally all the
manufacturers and you see this across
every every industry right you guys see
it too and i'm sure everybody sees it
with with food and whatnot but everybody
you know forecasted okay we're gonna
we're gonna wind down we're gonna we're
gonna you know tighten up our balance
sheet we're going to uh you know slow
things down and then all of a sudden you
started to see the federal government
come in the mortgage bond market you
started to see liquidity stay there and
there was a period of time where they
didn't know what was going to happen
with the mortgage bond market and um
and so you know naturally these home
builders were saying whoa you know i
don't know if we should really be
building this much so then they had all
of a sudden restart the race right and
you this time you're restarting the race
with lower interest rates
you had the federal government buying
the mortgage backed securities and so um
it's just been a natural game of
catch-up and that's what it's been i
mean it's it's been unbelievable i think
it's been
the biggest supply shock that the the
industry has ever seen and i know we're
seeing that in other industries as well
yeah what feels uh even worse is like
when you get the home prices going up uh
some of that naturally was just going to
happen by people wanting to move out of
cities move into suburban areas uh you
get the imbalance of supply demand so
forget all the monetary and fiscal
policy stuff like there already was
going to be higher price points just
because of this when you layer in the
monetary and fiscal policy stuff then
also it just explodes i mean 20 increase
right in terms of home prices from july
of last year to this year
sure you can say there's a base effect
in terms of prices went down during the
summer last year whatever you want to
say no you take the 20 questions out of
the mortgage market you'll see those
prices go down rapidly yeah why do you
think the government buying the
mortgage-backed securities is so uh
concerning because
and i do think it is but i not saying
so much concerning as much as it's a
reality now i mean the mortgage industry
you know has had third-party providers
who provided liquidity almost like a
market maker type situation
but when the federal government it's
much like um you know with interest
rates and the government backstopping
buying the government the government
buys treasury bonds right it just
creates this confidence that people have
to keep the liquidity going and so if
you feel that the government's always
going to bail you out in the in the
instance of mortgages right
are you going to be concerned is about
risk as much as you would if there
wasn't the government there right yeah
so if you take if you take the risk off
the table you know then you're looking
back at uh
you know some pretty risky things that
can happen what do you guys think
actually before you guys answer real
quick uh we're at 3.2 k likes right now
if you all get us to 4 000 likes john
will give away a thousand bucks and i'll
do it i'll do a thousand at 5 000.
there we go he finally shows up
should i put out a tweet and get it to 5
000. let's see if we can get there uh on
the count of three i'm going to count to
three press the like button when we hit
4 000 likes then john will go ahead and
give away a thousand bucks one two three
press that thumbs up button so more
people on youtube see this content and
they can learn alongside you all right
what do you guys think about the uh
increasing home prices
uh well i'm actually i'm shocked that
it's it's uh lasted this long in this
consistently across all parts of the
country right so if you look at kind of
the charts that we were showing earlier
it's not very uh it's not it's some
cities yeah sure five ten percent up
some are twenty percent las vegas i saw
this up 22 percent uh last month but
it's just like bill said right it's just
supply and demand people are moving uh
there's not enough inventory in the
market and people are willing to pay
much higher cost and not only that but
there's investors that are going out and
purchasing a lot of these properties
that's another big issue right yeah so
like when you look at it from the the
context of just even
literally a simple supply and demand a
lot more of it starts to make sense um
but we're going to see how long it lasts
for i think people are getting worried
that they're not going to be able to
afford or be able to move or be able to
purchase new homes uh already at some of
the prices that were that we're seeing
existing now so we'll see like if this
lasts for another three four or five
months where prices continue to climb up
over time it's going to be a real issue
over over time obviously the prices have
increased i saw a study that bloomberg
did the other day that basically was
like if you want to put that 20 down on
the average home in america it uh it's
going up and up and up right so now it's
you have to save for 10 years so the
lower income people in america are
actually getting hit harder than that
it's going to be harder to find home and
it's going to take longer to kind of get
um
into a home which can be seen as both an
asset and a liability right as a
standpoint but just owning a home is
very important and uh unfortunately it's
going to take longer to do that yeah the
other piece that becomes really
interesting is when you layer on the
increasing home prices uh that means
that everyone in a neighborhood the
value of their home is going up if the
value of their homes going up and we get
the unrealized capital gains tax now all
of a sudden and i think that this is
probably the the key piece are people
going to be forced to sell their homes
to pay the unrealized capital gains tax
right if you think of the average
american majority of their net worth is
in their home so let's say that you own
a 250 000 house and you've got a
mortgage on it you're paying off that
mortgage and you've got you know let's
say 50 000 of cash in your bank account
you got some stocks whatever but the
home is the majority of your net worth
you don't have enough cash to pay if the
home goes up 20
but that you just you you can't pay out
of your bank account or whatever without
putting yourself in a dire financial
position to pay that tax and so i don't
think we're gonna get in a world where
we want people selling their homes to
pay for a tax on an unrealized capital
gains which either means that there's
gonna be a carve out or they're gonna
have to say look this unreal is capital
gains sticks nuts
yeah i mean that's why it makes no sense
right
it's not gonna happen yeah it's it's
do do we think that uh we've got craig
lazara uh i think is the uh quote that
we have here uh who said quote the last
several months have been extraordinary
not only the level of price gains but in
the consistency of gains across the
country and then we've got danielle hale
who's the chief economist for
realtor.com so demand remains quite high
relative to just about any other period
in history which is what's driving
higher than normal price increases and
so both of these folks seem to be
highlighting demand uh or looking at
things around the extraordinary length
of this
but i think again i just go back to like
how much is just the dollar being
devalued right it's just monetary and
fiscal policy stuff playing out like
it feels like that's harder to point to
it's harder to grasp like hey how is
this working and so it's easy to oh
demands up right of course prices go up
or oh there's supply chain issues
construction companies uh one thing i
heard was some construction companies
were pausing new construction builds
when lumber prices were exploding
because they were saying that uh hey i
can't price your home because i
literally don't know what the price of
the goods is and that's true but i think
it's just a confluence of all these
events right and to your point yeah you
can sum it up to the dollar being down
for example but that's where i'm getting
at with the fed uh buying these
mortgage-backed securities is what are
they buying it with
they're buying it with u.s dollars right
yeah and so you know you talk about m2
and the velocity of money right at what
point does that all catch up but i think
they're probably going to taper
uh the mortgage-backed security buying
pretty soon so it'll be interesting to
see what happens what do you think of
the market
um i think that they're going to
probably reduce it because it's almost
like emergency like conditions i mean
there was a real concern for a period of
a few days in early 2020 that the
mortgage bond market was going to blow
up and if it wasn't for this outside
force meaning the government coming in
and doing it so i think they'll probably
lessen the amount of bonds that they're
buying and you know maybe you'll see an
uptick in rates but i still think
because of all the issues we discussed
the confluence of things
it's still going to be a hot market i i
was looking at a chart uh a minute ago
here from charlie uh bolello
but so he was showing the media and home
prices uh in the us over the last 10
years in august in august 2011 the
median home price was 220 000
and this august it's 391 thousand
dollars so it's almost nearly doubled in
the last decade so super scary stuff
there but then when you also look at the
uh the the median home price compared to
someone's income it's 5.8 times higher
than their median household income now
the average home price which is the
highest it's ever been on record 5.8
times someone's income their house the
median house in the u.s that's nuts yeah
but this is the highest it's ever been
it's free money everywhere for everyone
no problem you could pay for whatever
you want here all right we're closing in
on 4k likes john are you gonna be ready
do you know what you're gonna have
people do when uh once we hit the 4k
likes is that the most likes you've ever
had
uh
i think probably yeah that's why 5k
would definitely be uh would definitely
be the highest we hit 4 000 likes so
make sure you guys are hitting the
thumbs up john's gonna give away a
thousand dollars you have a question in
mind or what you want people to do i'm
thinking of it right now all right i
won't i won't uh call you out on it yet
uh but bill can you talk to us about uh
twitter philanthropy is there one like
story that uh you've done that you're
like wow that really felt like we really
you know helped somebody and stands out
to you yeah they're you know one of the
things that i think so cool about
twitter in all the social media is that
you can use it for good and you can help
people who otherwise wouldn't get the
help there was a baby in colorado that
was dying of a
spinal disease and i found out about it
i started tweeting it and having my
teammates because i call my my followers
my teammates because we're really a team
and it's like you know how they call the
bitcoin cyber hornets we you know it's
almost like this this team of cyber
hornets that i sick on people too
to help philanthropically right so all
of a sudden they start a novartis you
know the big drug company so we got
novartis to to give her the drug i mean
this is the words of the mom not not me
saying this and we did it and and so
that was a huge success so we basically
saved this girl's life she was i think
one or two years old at the time so that
was a huge huge twitter philanthropy
success and that was back that was back
a couple of years ago and that was
really our first big win with twitter
philanthropy and since then we've just
had way too many stories to count but
that's definitely probably that's pretty
cool right it's not just how do we give
money it's also kind of uh showing
engagement online and being able to kind
of incentivize people to do stuff that's
really powerful mobilizing bitcoiners
understand that really yeah
bill like what would be uh what is the
end goal right is it to create this kind
of infrastructure where you're able to
organically help a lot of people with
other people helping and chipping in and
doing all this stuff also that's exactly
right many hands make like work
you got it that's it
and i think bitcoin helps helps a lot of
that right because especially even with
the lightning network and now you're
able to
send money over twitter you know
instantaneously
this will do a lot of the heavy lifting
that i have to do on a daily basis
because you know yeah i'll still vet
kidney patients i'll still help cancer
patients i'll still help you know
average people who need help
but uh if other people can help other
people that's my end game so
we'll see where it goes it's just been a
natural organic movement and it's still
going now after two years which they say
you know is is really good that means
there's really something here people
like helping other people i mean that's
really what it's all about right that's
actually interesting to think about how
like venmo when they started they were
they were going after the payment
solutions of how do you send
peer-to-peer money very easily very
cheap um and then we're gonna build this
social aspect with it and twitter just
basically did the exact opposite they
built a massive social media company for
years and then added in the payment
solutions later correct yeah yeah people
thought i was crazy when i first started
giving money over twitter i mean
absolutely crazy i know it looks
somewhat normal these days but in 2019
you know i had a cash app which i think
you know not a lot of people had cash
apps
and
um
you know i started giving money on my
friends were saying hey is your account
hacked you know like something's not
right right
and um the thing just took off and it
was viral and that's frankly why i
actually went and bought a bunch of
square stock
a long time ago because because i was
using cash i was like wow this is like
magic right it's kind of like a tesla i
have a tesla and i own a lot of tesla
stock too because because it's just
magic it's magic right bill polti
invested magic
i do i do uh so
anyway so i saw it coming with square
and cash app and stuff like that and
then i saw the virality of what i was
doing i was like this is the future you
know i think i've even talked to you
over the last couple of years just you
know hitting you saying hey
they got to make this when square and
cat when square and twitter are going to
merge
i listen i thought it was going to
happen now i'm not so convinced because
now they integrated the payment stuff so
they might not have to do it i agree but
don't underestimate jack dorsey yeah we
agree on that friend so you know who
knows what he's what he's up to
all right we've hit 4.1 k likes which
means john's giving away a thousand
bucks right now good guy john noted good
guy future potential mayor of miami uh
bill you don't know this but yesterday
we determined that maybe john might run
for mayor of miami once sworn i think uh
your brothers and i will be head of the
finance committee perfect perfect
uh what do you want people to do so you
could pick one person to give a thousand
bucks to drop in the chat where you are
watching from today and then drop your
twitter handle as well so i can make
sure to reach out to you so you can get
it
where people are is that where are you
watching from today where people are
watching from what do we think the
craziest place somebody's watching from
right now
i don't know what what like henderson
texas define crazy yeah so i was like i
don't know yeah i don't know about crazy
but we got morocco indiana cincinnati
iowa
colorado
india
vietnam and if you guys are palm beach
florida if you guys are my teammates my
followers go hit subscribe these guys
are great they'll give you a lot of
thoughts on how to make money how to
look at the world differently i think
they're disrupting their space so that's
really exciting so hit subscribe hit
like
the best business show only has the best
guess you know right yeah go harass pump
all right john what do you got for us i
got um danny connell watching from his
living room in connecticut
that's who you picked
all right you win i just tagged them uh
make sure you hey when you give away
money you pick who you want to pick hey
that's fine enough john joe you may not
be picking anyone well if we get to 5
000 likes we're only 900 away so if we
get to 5 000 likes you'll give away a
thousand dollars too yeah
in like real dollars or monopoly money
bitcoin
all right there you go if we get to 5
000 likes joe will give away a thousand
bucks in bitcoin but we have an hour to
hit that right yeah we got we got plenty
of time
i was going to do some emergency tweets
don't help this is now joe's time joe
gets the 5 000 likes we're oh 4.2 or 800
away all right we'll see what happens
that's fine uh john people are asking if
uh you're single in the chat i am
all right we got michael saylor who
tweeted out uh yesterday i think this is
saying uh there is no inflation as long
as you don't wish to buy anything going
up in price uh which is obviously a
tongue-in-cheek way to say inflation is
absolutely out of control now the u.s
stock market took it on the chin again
tuesday who wrote that is that uh from a
cnbc article by the way we can ask you a
question about microstrategy and michael
sailor how much do you think michael
saylor will be worth one day
i think that michael saylor
has two main drivers of his personal net
worth he has uh what was about 225 250
million dollars for the bitcoin that he
bought around um i think it was like 10
to 15 000
so uh let's say that that's up about 4x
so he probably has personally a billion
dollars worth of bitcoin wow um and then
he
owns a a considerable amount of micro
strategy stock i'm sure we can figure
out uh this is a ridiculous question do
you think he could be a trillionaire one
day i think that there's going to be a
lot of trillionaires uh in the future
and uh he's got a shot if you said to me
right now pick somebody who has a
shot to be the richest man in the world
yeah but is not on everyone's radar yeah
michael's saying i agree would be the
person who's got a shot yeah right he's
got uh he's got a 115 roughly thousand
bitcoin right now micro strategies
michael
yes
how much of the stock does he does do we
know but we make this joke that uh it
used to be a big deal to be a
millionaire then it became a big deal to
be a billionaire and now it's going to
be a really big deal when people start
to aspire to be trillionaires that's
right that's why the trump trillionaire
energy came from because i love her i
was going to steal that sweater you can
have this one no problem because if i do
that then i can help even more people
because it is expensive but uh right
owns like it looks like he owns about uh
2.4 million shares two point about 24 of
the company all right so he owns 24 of
the company which means he's got of a
5.6 billion dollar business he's got
another billion you know billion and a
half dollars or so of uh of
microstrategy stocks so right there
that's two and a half billion plus
whatever else um and so if you look at
that the richest people in the world
right now are somewhere between let's
call it a 180 220
uh billion right so he literally has a
hundred x
essentially
to go to just reach where they are yeah
but
i tend to think that uh you know he's
got a shot which is like pretty crazy
like what was his name bernard arnott
from lbmh yeah he came out of nowhere
right i mean he was only worth 30
billion maybe 20 billion uh before the
pandemic and then the pandemic hit and
stock took off
now he he elon musk and jeff bezos have
like a daily competition as to who's
going to be the richest man in the world
yeah i mean 115 000 bitcoin if it goes
to a million 5 million that's somewhere
between 100 and 500 billion why are you
so bearish i'm just saying
those are numbers that i think people
will at least like consider
you know if i if i say a number too low
you'll complain if i say number two high
other people will complain joe just is
trying to get to the five thousand likes
now he's like yeah yeah a million bucks
whatever hey
thousand dollars of bitcoin could be
worth a lot more y'all are giving
depreciating money away all right relax
danny you can pick bitcoin or cash up to
you
john all right we've got the uh u.s
stock market taking it on the chin again
tuesday i'm assuming that we used our
outsourced uh research friends over at
bloomberg and uh the u.s treasury yields
continue rising we've got a couple of uh
statistics here so the s p market had
its worst session since may it was down
two percent which by the way we can just
talk about it in the stock market the
yell and scream when the stock market
goes down one or two percent in bitcoin
it goes down 10 people don't even talk
about it they're just like uh whatever
it's just a normal day nasdaq had its
worst day since march it was down 2.8
percent getting real froggy almost three
percent and the dow was the worst
decline since last week's sell-off down
1.6 on tuesday so literally people are
talking about how bad the stock market
did yesterday and it's down somewhere
between 1.6 to 2.8
absolute absurd when you look at what
young people hold as assets and the
volatility they're willing to endure and
so now treasury secretary janet yellen
has said that she expects inflation to
end 2021 somewhere near four percent
we've got two quotes and a couple of
three quotes and a couple charts first
quote inflation is elevated and will
likely remain so in coming months before
moderating jerome powell by the way i
love when they say that it is elevated
as if that's like a surprise we've been
saying it over and over again check the
receipts since last year of course this
was going to happen but hey what do we
know all we do is we just play on the
internet next up we have ryan dietrich
the senior market strategist at lpl
financial said the big picture is the
sudden surge in the past week of yields
which has led to a sell first ask
questions later mentality the back and
forth in washington with the debt
ceiling and the spending bill and
potential higher taxes have weighed on
overall investor psyche and has led to a
pretty good sized sell-off we then have
this chart of the us treasury yields the
past three months we're going up we're
going we're going up we're going up next
we have a quote from kathy jones that
says the market's been steadily coming
around to the reality that yields were
awfully low relative to the fundamentals
now the fed is shifting and everybody's
shifting their positions all at once as
we tend to do now my favorite chart that
we're gonna show you today is this one
which is every time that the us debt
ceiling we get close that's the ones in
yellow uh
it gets raised and it gets increased and
somehow someway we always find a way to
avoid the catastrophe all of the
doomsdayers all of the people who go out
there and tell you be careful the world
is going to end the u.s is going to
default it's not going to happen it's
all a charade no one's going to default
they're literally going to end up either
raising the debt limit or creating a
spending bill to get around this issue
sphere porn that's exactly what it is
it's complete nonsense uh it's very
similar to your point about the
unrealized tax uh capital gains tax is
there is we we did it yesterday i think
there is uh
literally next to zero percent chance of
a default in the united states yeah and
and it's
it's sad to see these treasury
secretaries come out and you know try to
claim like it is world war iii and it's
like dude we know you're full of [ __ ]
so it's just like why are you even
saying that yeah well and i think
another piece of it is uh i get that
like yes technically this will happen
but they act like there's nothing else
we can do other than raise the debt
ceiling and in some crazy way uh the
debt ceiling doesn't matter right like
if you really think about it it's just
this like random rule that we created
and then we say oh yeah this is the debt
ceiling and then we yell and scream
about well we should move it again like
what the debt ceiling right now is what
what is this 28 uh
trillion i think right
so 28.4 trillion let's just make it 100
trillion like stop this like every year
we gotta like move the debt like just
make the debt ceiling 100 trillion like
that's where we're going anyway so just
go ahead and move it there and then we
don't have to talk about it for like
three years and then we'll compare they
still get paid even if they don't raise
the debt limit right
of course yeah
so yeah it's it's all nice yeah it's
rigged
all right
um one of the things i want to talk
about bill is when you think about uh
your career in buildings a lot of young
people who watch this uh what are some
of the things that you learned early on
that you're like wow if i had known that
even earlier or things that maybe you
know now that you're like if i if i had
learned that stuff earlier in my career
i could have leveraged that whether it
was uh if you had been inside of a
corporation building your own business
uh or just kind of doing transactions
etc what are some of those lessons
learned
you know i've been reflecting on that a
lot lately because
one of the things i've been doing is
funding a lot of businesses with
entrepreneurs kind of like what you do
and
uh you know
it sounds crazy but i would just say you
know do the work do the work uh you know
so many people try to look for the short
the shortcut or the quick work or
whatever i'll give you an example i just
invested in an air conditioning business
and the guy who runs it he's below 30 i
don't want to say exactly who he is and
he keeps looking and he's watching all
these different podcasts and everything
and his real talent is selling air
conditioning and i just said to him i
said stop watching all these podcasts
stop reading all these books just go
sell the units door to door and you know
he doesn't want to hear that but so i
would just say do the work you know
watch pomp show
learn what you can here learn what you
can other places but you just gotta do
the work and i think that with this
liquidity that's in the market right now
if you do the work
there are so many options to get paid
for it right now i mean it's just
ridiculous i mean can you believe that
they're selling us they're allowing us
to buy bitcoin at these prices right now
so you know go sell some air
conditioning units or go sell you know
whatever right and you know stack sats
how important do you think it is for
young people to learn like what i'd call
like the basics of business so
accounting selling um you know uh kind
of strategy operations like those key
components versus hey i already know
that i have an inclination to be good at
sales i already know if you're good at
it you should lean into it i think and
hire the best people around you right at
least that's how i've done it and
everybody i know who's been successful
right i mean even you you've hired
people who you know round out your skill
set so
so yeah just kind of lean into exactly
what lean into what you do don't run
away from it people try to do it now i
do think that there are some basic
things right that you can learn for
example i think one of the things that
uh you know good entrepreneurs good
young people can learn is finance
because finance to me is the language of
of business and so um you know a lot of
people give a lot of different advice
you know i'm trying to avoid giving
advice and just saying hey do the work
and if you are going to learn you know
some type of skill set to augment it
finance because uh so often i run into
these businesses i'm sure you do too i
think
sometimes you're you're investing with
people maybe you have more finance
background a lot of people i'm dealing
with don't have a finance background and
they don't really know how much money
they're taking home at the end of the
day and and the inability to know how
much money you're netting after you pay
the government
um
you know a lot of people don't realize
they they have a business partner and
even if they don't have a business
partner and that is the federal
government because they have to pay 40
of their taxes and so i think really
understanding finance can really help
you become a wealthy you know wealthy
individual because if you if you know
your core skill set you hit it home you
hire around it and then you you really
understand finance to know how much
you're netting and putting in the bank
you know one day you'll wake up and
you'll be wealthy and you've got to have
you got to have ten dollars before you
have a hundred dollars you gotta have a
hundred dollars before you have a
thousand dollars right so you gotta have
a million dollars before you have 10
million and that was my experience too
it feels like um there's a uh
a key component
to
um
the way you talk about it i talk to
founders all the time and they'll always
say uh hey you know i make uh i make 10
million dollars in my business and they
talk about top line reference correct
right and then you say okay well what do
you do after expenses and then they'll
give you a number exactly and then
you're like okay now what after that
like you gotta like literally walk
through it and that's what your point is
that 10 million actually end up maybe
two million yeah right i say revenue is
vanity and profitability is sanity ah i
like that uh my grandfather taught it to
me and um
yeah it was just a great one because
everybody they go around these industry
trade shows at least in our industry
beat their chest oh look at how big my
revenue is and then you know it's like
okay dude but show me your bank account
how much did you take home at the end of
the day you know
i know john likes that yeah i do i also
think it's uh besides this business it's
personal finance as well right so that's
what i mean by yeah 33 of millionaires
never made over 100k which i think is an
unreal stat to speaking it speaks to
money management and uh the ability to
turn that ten dollars into a hundred
dollars and hundred dollars into a
thousand dollars and when we use finance
we use all these words all these labels
finance is just a fancy way in my
opinion for saying math right and so
understand the math of how you keep
score in your business i mean that's
really what you're doing right i mean
it's like it's like playing in a
football game and not having an accurate
scoreboard you've got to have an
accurate scoreboard otherwise you know
what do you what are you playing the
game for here's a wild stat for you that
uh i was talking to uh our father uh
over the weekend and he said this to me
and i literally was like i don't believe
you and so of course he as soon as we
got off the phone sent me like 17 000
links to like prove to me that uh that
it was right but uh can you guys do a
show with your parents sometime oh
he my dad would love it
we will discuss and negotiate with him
because all we'll offer is hey listen
we'll come see you guys if you don't we
just heard about the math and you've got
to get the finances right you negotiate
for them
uh so this study shows that uh they
surveyed 10 000
millionaires it's the ramsey solutions
conducted the largest survey of
millionaires ever 10 000 participants
and the top five careers of people who
become a millionaire they have engineers
they have accountants they have
management and they have attorneys there
are four of the five what do you think
the fifth one is so engineer accountant
management attorney the fifth one is one
you would not expect that is the highest
career or the highest concentration of
millionaires in a single uh
uh
occupation sales people
no agriculture no lawyers doctors
uh so attorneys are in attorney but yeah
teachers
engineers accountants management
attorney and teachers
and he was telling me he was like yeah
one of the top five professions for
people to become a millionaire is a
teacher and i think most people are
conditioned
well most people are conditioned to
think hey
teachers don't get paid a lot of money
they get paid 40 50 60 000 depending on
if it's public or private but they know
math where they are
well even better than that is they're
super disciplined
the person that ends up becoming a
teacher from like a psychological
standpoint they're not trying to go buy
a yacht right they're not trying to go
buy the the ferrari they usually end up
being uh somebody who hey i want to go
to work i want to i want to teach people
they live within their means they have
kind of financial discipline and they'll
become your millionaire and so it makes
sense you know you think engineers uh
and uh and management or attorneys they
make a lot of money they have kind of
high top-line
income and so can they become a
millionaire but when you look at
accountants like okay they understand
accounting like they'll figure it out
but teachers i think is like really
interesting because it completely
dispels one of the things that most
people think is true is like oh you have
to make a ton of money most teachers
really don't make that much money right
but it is one of the top five careers
for millionaires that makes me feel good
hearing that why that teachers are doing
well financially because it's always
been the narrative someone just said in
the comments
it's cheating because they can get
summer jobs like no that's not the story
yeah
they have two jobs
that's an all-time comment so i just
quickly searched the average salary of a
teacher and salary.com has between forty
thousand and seventy thousand zip
recruiter has it between sixteen
thousand and forty thousand uh and then
glassdoor has between thirty thousand
and sixty thousand so let's call it
somewhere between you know twenty to
maybe sixty or seventy thousand dollars
uh to be a public school teacher and uh
we know that thirty three percent of
millionaires like john said have never
made more than 100k in a single year um
and one of the top five professions to
become a millionaire as a teacher so
it's pretty damn cool when you start to
understand so what's the thought process
behind that you can either make a lot of
money or you can be really disciplined
well the holy grail is you do both right
is you have incredible earning potential
you make a ton of money and then on top
of that you're financially disciplined
so you actually end up getting there
faster you end up compounding it and
whatever but even if you don't make a
lot like again think about it if you if
you start working at the age of 22 right
and you get paid 50 000 a year
i'm not a mathematician but you only
need to work 20 years and now you've
been paid a million dollars of top line
income now you've got expenses you've
got to pay taxes you got to do all this
stuff so but you can also invest you can
invest you can do all this stuff right
but like you've already been paid a
million dollars by the time you're 42
years old and you're only making 50 000
a year and you're a teacher so what
happens if you become financially
disciplined and let's say that you can
save a big portion of that well okay now
you've been working for 30 years then 40
years right like at some point by the
time you hit retirement if you've been
paid 50 000 a year you literally made
two million bucks
in top line revenues it's to kind of
bill's point it's not how much you made
it's how much did you keep yeah right
and so if you just put let's say uh uh
double that right now it's not 50 it's
100.
well in 10 years you've literally made
a million dollars in top line revenue
yeah and this applies
some people in the comments are are
giving us a hard time because it's
it's like we're saying teachers are
millionaires and and the point is really
yeah they are no they they literally are
some of the time that's what the stats
says
like literally teachers are millionaires
like it is one of the top five
professions to become a millionaire in
the united states but but it's it could
be applied to anyone at that income
level is my point oh for sure yeah i'm
not saying that they're getting paid a
million dollars a year that's how become
a millionaire i'm saying that they
likely have uh a propensity for living
within their means more so than anybody
else like we all went to school i don't
remember a teacher showing up in a
corvette
right like i don't remember them
spending like lavishly frankly most of
them kind of showed up to school and
they probably were wearing the same
clothes they'd worn for a while and like
it was just like that's just what they
do they go to school they teach you know
uh during the school year and then they
leave well to the point about the math
you know they have to count what
resources they have because there's
little of it right so they have to count
in order to feed themselves where i
think people get into trouble is
especially in business and you start
selling products for example to your
point you can look at the revenue line
item and you can say oh my god look at
how much money i'm making and that
revenue can be very deceiving right so
um it doesn't surprise me yeah what do
you think are uh some of the key things
that you did in your life from like a
finance standpoint in terms of uh not
maybe not understanding what to do but
uh
like good habits that you have that
you're like okay if it doesn't matter if
you make a gazillion dollars a year or
you make one dollar a year if you have
these types of habits like i think that
really puts you on the right path i
would say you know how i made my first
let's say million or two million dollars
which was really really important to me
because that really gave me the
confidence to to go forward was that i
bought businesses
where i bought into things that had cash
flows and what i mean by that is i
bought positive cash flowing things a
lot of people like to buy negative cash
flow and i know you like to start you
know small and incubate and lose money
that's true is if you focus on
positive cash flow entities you can make
your life a lot easier in my opinion and
what happens is you get compounding
working for you you get the
it's almost like a law of nature
compounding it can work for you or
against you and so i would just say you
know be a little bit patient now it took
me several years to make my first
million or two but then once i figured
that out and i got the law of
compounding working for me it just went
like straight up like a hockey stick so
you know again this is unsexy advice
right but uh yeah but it works yeah it
works buy cash by positive cash flowing
thanks could be anything could be an
apartment could be a read could be a
business could be whatever and just let
it sit there and cash day after day
after day because if you look at the
bank account day after day after day you
say wow i'm not making that much money
but then when you start looking at it
you know after 30 days 60 days 120 days
right this stuff starts to pile up and
over a period of years you know you'll
wake up in three or five years and you'd
be worth a shitload of money and then
sorry i don't know if i can swear you
could say whatever you want and then the
internet yeah i know but like jimmy's
channel you can't
say anything bad on it because i don't
know um but i forget what i was saying
but so anyway so if you just compounded
over time you know uh
you know i think that if i had to start
all over again that's what i'd do yeah
uh one of the things that we talk about
a lot is uh how this weekend somebody
can go out and make a thousand bucks
right so just like all these ideas and
one time joe uh which is crazy because i
think when we graduated from college i
don't know i mean it
thousand dollars was a lot that was i
mean it was right so
yeah i mean a thousand dollars still a
lot yeah i say one dollars a lot but
yeah it's it's a lot but but the amount
of purchasing power for a thousand
dollars today even versus you know
2005 2010 like anywhere in that time
frame uh you know look at the inflation
level right we've literally just in the
last year 38 of all dollars during the
last 18 months have been uh printed
inflation the official numbers are up
over five percent so i mean it's pretty
crazy how much uh purchasing power's
been lost but one of the things that uh
we we talked about was jokes was
basically like hey if i want to make a
thousand dollars what i would do is i
should go to local country club and i
would caddy basically i'd go surround
myself with rich people right and in
some weird way like some money would
fall out of their pockets into mine
right i think too like the the
difference too is like are you looking
to build something sustainable that can
grow and scale and make more money and
become something with enterprise value
or whatever right like that's one
scenario but if you tell me you have
until the end of the weekend to make a
thousand dollars like what's the most
high upside thing i can think of that's
probably manual labor that you actually
have to go outside and go do something
for it's probably the country club right
you go to a golf course and you caddy
for some people and you try to find your
way to get some cash other than that
it's going to be hard to start something
within 24 48 hours online and build
something yeah but even then like let's
say you put away the thousand dollars
let's say you put in bitcoin or
something else over time that will
compound to be significant and you know
i think a lot of people could look at
you pump and think oh well you know
pomp's so successful and you know he's
investing in all these businesses and
everything but you're kind of an outlier
in a sense that you know
you have access to deals that very few
people have and whatnot so somebody
might be watching this and they might
not have the access to the vc channels
for example that you have
excuse me and so it's a horrible idea to
angel invest if you're basically sitting
pretty much anywhere in the world other
than uh you don't have to physically be
in these geographies anymore but you
have to be in the networks and if you
know i just go out on the street and i
just ask people like hey what's certain
business i want to invest i'm going to
lose money for sure exactly right
because it's just you let's say let's do
that reverse so let's say you go out to
the street and you say hey put your
thousand dollars in this reit i don't
know making up some you know
some some reit i mean yeah they could
depreciate it but are they going to lose
money doing that that would not and
probably not right yeah well the reits
and then also you could even do it for
not all businesses but a lot of the s p
500 you know oh yeah you can even go
back buy
you can even go and uh and invest in
local businesses right we had somebody
come on uh cody sanchez who basically
talked all about like uh one of the
businesses that she bought into was she
went to somebody they owned a like a
mailbox business which was kind of like
if you ever go to the post office and
have like po boxes similar type of
business but it was the local mom and
pop one and uh she went to them and said
hey i love your business uh i think that
maybe you need help you know either
marketing or kind of getting the word
out uh but i'd like to buy into the
business and so she gave them you know
not a small amount of money but but also
not millions of dollars i don't know
what 50 100 000 whatever it was uh and
she bought like i think it was
maybe a third of the business and the
business was doing you know 250 000
in uh cash flow yeah right and she's
like wait a minute i just bought
like this is like a no-brainer type deal
yeah and so you don't necessarily have
to go and invest in the next next
facebook to be able to make money right
it's the reason why there is so much
asymmetry in early stage technology is
because there's so much risk
right you you basically are getting paid
for the risk that you're taking i think
people forget that point about it right
is they always want to say oh i can make
a bunch of money everyone always looks
at the upside
but the downside is zero
versus a reit or something like that
that you know again sure on a very very
outlier case that could happen but the s
p 500 is not going to zero exactly right
and so the risk is very different so you
should expect you can get a 30 return in
the s p 500 and have you know what's the
downside uh
maybe it goes down 30 percent the
government steps in and you know pumps
according to the market like it did in
may of last year or march last year okay
like that's a pretty good trade-off
exactly and then if you look over a long
period of time like the stock market is
not allowed to go down right you know
like it's not it's not that instant
gratification you can look at it every
day and say oh wow look at how much
money i made or whatever i mean maybe
buy something with more volatility like
bitcoin but the spy over time you know
you make money the damn thing just keeps
going it's the classic saying uh time in
the market not timing the market
compounding if you don't know anything
about investing compound compounding is
the greatest thing in the world you know
john has got some fire one-liners today
what'd you say earlier uh uh how many
hands many hands make light work yeah
which is very true when i was like 21 i
i asked mitt romney it was kind of weird
uh and i don't know well at all but i
asked him i said you know what what's
the key to your success at bain capital
and he said
my key is i buy something for the right
price and i have a spinning ball effect
and to me
the spinning ball was always that
compound interest so at bain i guess you
know this is what he was arguing to me
and it just always stuck with me since i
was like 21 right and so i don't know i
just i just try to like literally other
than give away my money on twitter which
frankly i like to use the compounding to
fund what i'm doing on twitter but um
you know that's what i try to do every
day you know buy stuff that's low
that's spitting out cash and then just
have that spinning ball effect yeah it i
mean it's a no-brainer this was not to
say oh i talked to mitt romney once no
it's not
i'm not into that what i'm saying is
this guy built a really good business i
was 21 years old it was it was a very
impactful conversation to me everyone
was mad at mitt romney that he had like
250 million dollars in his retirement
account until people figured out that
peter two had five billion and like
everyone's forgot about romney now right
like it's all about uh deal uh speaking
of uh people who uh who are quite
wealthy and well-known uh elon musk
yesterday said that the u.s government
uh basically shouldn't regulate the
crypto market he was at the uh i think a
recode or code they might have changed
the name uh out in beverly hills in la
and he was asked on stage what he
thought about regulation in the crypto
market
we do know that one elon owns a material
percent of bitcoin in his net worth uh
we also know that tesla has purchased
about a billion billion and a half
dollars worth of bitcoin earlier this
year they sold 10 percent uh to test
liquidity and then tesla also has
accepted bitcoin as payment in the past
he has two quotes here the first one he
says i wouldn't say that i'm a massive
cryptocurrency expert
i think there's some value in
cryptocurrency but i wouldn't say it's
the second coming of the messiah very
strong words from elon then he also said
quote it is not possible to i think
destroy crypto but it is possible for
governments to slow down its advancement
and so i think generally his point is
look you can't destroy it you could slow
it down but there's a lot of things that
we could focus on regulating this space
more than it already is probably doesn't
make as much sense as some of the
trade-offs so what else you could do i
appreciate him saying that he's not an
expert in the space uh just speaks to
like his openness and what he's like
really um i don't think anyone was
confused on that
yeah but you you've also you've said a
lot of times that bitcoin is actually in
the cryptocurrency space it's actually
more regulated than the traditional
finance space um can you expand on that
so well if you think about uh the reason
why
i say it
if i go tonight and i buy dinner right
me and john go uh to dinner and i have
dinners on you tonight sure and when i
pay for the meal i pay for the cost of
the meal let's say the meal is 50 bucks
right or we have inflation so it's 100
then i pay sales tax
and if i buy it with dollars that's it
cost of the meal sales tax but if i buy
with bitcoin i pay the cost of the meal
i pay sales tax and i have to pay
capital gains on my bitcoin
not really uh conducive to using bitcoin
right so it's over regulated compared to
using dollars on top of that in the
financial capital of the world in new
york city
it is harder to start a crypto company
than it is a traditional financial
company and so if i want to start let's
say a fintech business i go and i get
all the licenses that i need i get my
broker dealer license i do my kyc aml
get my money transmitter license all
that stuff and i get uh my business up
and running and i'm good to go if i want
to start a crypto company i have to do
all those same things money transmitter
broker dealer aml kyc etc then i have to
apply for a new separate license just to
operate a crypto company called a bit
license in new york and they've only
given out on a handful of them so it's
harder to start a crypto company than it
is a traditional financial company which
ends up meaning that the businesses are
more regulated in crypto than they are
in the legacy world
yeah i mean i also think it's important
to note that he's obviously financially
incentivized for it not to get regulated
in a negative way right so
tesla owns bitcoin uh i don't know if
they still allow customers to pay for
things in bitcoin but he personally owns
a lot of bitcoin i think he owns some
other uh crypto also but it's a material
part of his holdings uh investments wise
and i think he only holds uh outside of
his public holdings of the companies he
owns or the equity in the companies that
he owns uh bitcoin is his largest
holding so it's important to recognize
that he is incentivized for the stuff to
happen but he's right right like we we
always talk about it a lot of times in
the context of the united states because
that's where we live but really when you
look around the world uh the country and
the the local governments and the people
that adopt these technologies and create
infrastructure uh and rules and
regulations to incentivize people to
come there and build on top of these
networks and advance the innovation of
these products are going to be the ones
that are the most successful
and i think what he's saying is look
like you're not going to stop a lot of
this stuff that's already happening now
they're decentralized networks there's
not much you can do outside of taxation
and a few other things
so why wouldn't you just innovate on top
of that right why wouldn't you allow a
safe space for people to come and build
product services etc
on these networks and on these protocols
and i think what we're going to see is
the governments that allow people to do
that and enable people to go do that are
going to benefit the most and the ones
that do it the earliest are going to
benefit the most and i think what elon
musk is saying is like hey look why
shouldn't the united states be uh the
leader in that space right if you want
to be the global superpower that you
always talk about you should be the one
that are allowing people to come and
innovate and do all the uh kind of
representing the ethos that your your
country uh says they represent all the
time
completely i don't think more regulation
uh necessarily deters innovation i think
it can kind of go both ways if you do
too much regulation in a bad manner it
can definitely uh stop innovation but
innovation's gonna happen uh and like he
said you can't you're not gonna be able
to kill crypto you're not gonna be able
to kill bitcoin bitcoin right you can
over regulate it and make it super
annoying for people you can do what
china didn't try to ban it but people
are still gonna use it completely agree
uh we are at four point six k likes if
we get i might be capable of a thousand
dollars
joe's gonna give away a thousand dollars
if we get to five thousand likes so make
sure you guys are hitting the uh hitting
the like button there so more people
youtube can find this uh i think that we
have a video uh that we're gonna pull up
here uh i don't know if you guys saw the
latest florida band video did you guys
see this i don't think there was a uh
there was an incident
where an alligator got loose
earlier yeah
we're gonna pull it up uh and jordy um
can uh can maybe help us uh in terms of
uh getting some of this pulled up here
um but the uh the thing about this video
that's so funny is awesome
is one not only did the guy do it right
did he fight the alligator uh but two
is he was like annoyed that he had to do
it he wasn't scared he was just like man
god like i gotta go do this right now
and he's sitting there with the uh my
favorite part of it is when he hits it
in the head with the uh with the lid and
the alligator's like hey what are you
doing
cause i thought we were having a
showdown i didn't realize this was like
a real thing here um so we're going to
pull it up in a in a second here but uh
if we get to 5 000 likes today then joe
will go ahead and give away 1 000
already bill's giving away a thousand
i've given away a thousand john's giving
away a thousand there's only one next if
we get 5 thousand likes should i do some
emergency tweets
let's wait a second i think we got a
little bit more time joe's gonna be
spending some cash today you already
spent cash yes i did i already talked to
danny too all right here we go here's
the video of this alligator look at them
this is an all-time way to capture an
alligator like this
let me know what they ain't going inside
let me know
somebody let me know
let me let me know let me know
all the things you got now
damn he's fighting to get back damn
because his friend said heads in so he
closed
it i mean this is crocodile d right here
look at him look at him he's like got
this dude legend the whole neighborhood
was clapping
if if uh you call like animal control
and they show up and they're like
where's the alligator like oh he's in
the trash can and like how did you get
in there and you show them this video
you're sitting on the trash can no you
think do you think they offer you a job
well you know animal control was pumped
when they got there and they're like
wait it's already done like it's already
y'all got it yeah this is the part right
here where he uh he smacks him on the
head that's the crazy part about this
video
it's coming up right here
yeah i don't mess with the alligators
man bam
jeez
because i don't think the alligators
really can go backwards that well
obviously
and then he gets them
guy deserves award
some i don't know what the awards for
but some kind of award for can you
imagine telling your buddies what you
did today yeah the only video that's
better than that is did you see when
that guy jumped in the lake and the uh
alligator had his little puppy and he
saw a cigar in his mouth and he pulled
open the alligators oh now that guy was
nice and the little puppy got away and
then he looked at the alligator like hey
man i had to get in the water and it was
like he's like older guy he literally
had a uh a sleeveless shirt on and a
cigar in his mouth
and it's like nobody believes you like
nobody believes that story let alone the
guy's like i jumped into the lake and i
wrestled with an alligator
that guy's forever a legend
yeah he's got a video to prove it too
it's all right by the way i saw one in
the comments a lot of people saying well
we don't have a whole lot of money to
invest and that's definitely an issue um
and and that's why i say one dollar is a
lot but to to my point earlier even on
the cash app you can invest one dollar
you can invest one dollar in bitcoin a
lot of people don't understand but with
bitcoin you you don't need to have fifty
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars to buy meaningful amounts of
bitcoin on cash app you can buy small
pieces of it so i just wanted to mention
that we um we also uh we did this
partnership with sofi and one of the
things that we did with sofi uh is all
these platforms allow you to buy stuff
right which is like the whole point to
it and we and we're always careful to
tell people like
we all like bitcoin right i think you
like bitcoin uh
i don't care what you invest in like it
almost doesn't matter what you invest in
right um as long as you get invested
because you get started you have a kind
of skin in the game to start paying
attention you'll start learning and all
this type of stuff but one of the things
that
we ran into over and over and over again
was
lots of people said hey i want to invest
but my biggest cost outside of rent and
food
credit card debt or student loan debt
etc so they have these products that
allow you to refinance that stuff lower
rates like there's a huge advantage of
doing that and then the other piece that
people forget is budgeting and saving
and so they have a whole like budgeting
saving tools kit that essentially shows
you it's kind of weird earlier like how
much money do you take home a lot of
people don't know that but also how much
money are you making like one of the
things we talk about a lot is uh i
always laugh i see like these like uh
kind of uh personal finance folks sort
of like you know bill you should try to
spend 200 less a month
and somebody's like dude i spent a
thousand dollars a month right i'm a
young kid like where do you want me to
carve out 200 of my thousand dollars of
expenses what they're probably 500 bucks
extra a month right so the the kind of a
mindset of abundance rather than hey how
do i not make more money um and it
always shocks me how many people are
like i'm not gonna buy starbucks today
like i'm gonna save the five dollars
like i don't know if that's necessarily
gonna make you rich but like i like the
mentality but the actual actionable
thing for people if you don't pay
yourself a ton of money yeah just go go
figure how do you make an extra 500 000
bucks even if you make 60 grand a year
70 80 grand a year an extra thousand
1500 500 a month can be meaningful
especially if it's all going to
investing versus trying to especially
now when people a lot of people aren't
willing to do the work right and so
like you said you can make so much money
right now i think
i don't think i don't know if this is
going to go on forever by the way i mean
i hope that the economy is as strong as
it is so do you mind talking about your
personal portfolio a little bit like
what uh what not necessarily financial
advice but what you see as opportunities
and what you kind of like sure so i own
a lot of the qqq so the technology etf i
own a lot of the spy and then i own a
lot of bitcoin
so
so yeah i have a lot of bitcoin i mean i
mean not as much as i probably should
but it's a lot so
and
what is the reason behind bitcoin and
the qqq
well the queues are getting beat up this
week because the interest rates a little
bit but um
my thought is that the queues are
businesses that are almost like
monopolies they're almost like cartels
it's sad to say but they are and so to
my point earlier about buying the
spinning ball effect i mean
google is a spinning ball it's going
down the street and it's generating i
mean what did did you guys hear this at
google's revenues like 30 growth rate i
mean this is insane after it's been
growing
as fast as it is and now it's growing
another thirty percent and it's ebitda
margins i don't know if you guys have
seen this but the ebitda margin is like
30 35 i mean these things
i mean they should be broken up right uh
but they're like cartels so i say to
people especially people not at means i
say you know again this is not
investment advice but i say you know go
buy the cartels go buy go buy the
monopolies like if that's the game we
have to play if that's how it's been
rigged
by the monopolies buy those
buy those big companies so i i hold a
lot of equity risk i don't view it as a
risk and it is risk but uh do you hold
bonds i don't yeah i feel like that's
probably the biggest thing no gold
i feel like that's probably the biggest
thing gold is a currency you know in my
opinion bitcoin is a commodity in my
opinion and i think it's becoming more
of a currency which is
which is going to be really exciting i
think yeah the the part to me uh is if
we went and talked to folks that we know
that are 60 70 years old everyone is 60
40. like that was the standard when you
go talk to younger people you know maybe
50s maybe down into some 40s they still
have 60 40 especially their financial
advisors that's still coming out of that
world whatever
john's 25 years old how many of your
friends got 40 in their portfolio and
bonds i don't know we talked to dylan
the other day he said he's over 100
percent allocated
to bitcoin oh yeah he said he was taking
out zero percent interest rate credit
cards last year to buy bitcoin
but
but i think that's the whole thing i
actually don't know if i have a friend
who outside of traditional money
management they're managing a fund where
the mandate is to hold some bonds i
don't think i could tell you a single
friend i have that owns bonds i'm in my
early 30s right certainly no one that
manages their own personal portfolio so
let me ask you a question to our earlier
question earlier who's buying the
mortgage bonds
oh it's all the government yeah the
here's the the craziest part of
investors are buying mortgage bonds
i wonder if we can figure out the
average pension investment portfolio
allocation but these are negative real
rates real negative interest rates right
you have the interest rate less
inflation
yeah all right so here is uh
all right we have the average
allocations
for
2019 average asset allocations in the
fortune 100
pension portfolios so fortune 100
companies in their pensions here's the
average asset allocation
now the average
distribution by class fifty percent of
it is in debt
right so all sorts of various debt
instruments three point three percent in
cash
equity is 36 percent private equity's 2
percent real estate's 2 hedge funds 2
others 3
so the largest holding in the fortune
100 pension portfolios is debt it's
bonds it's all sorts of uh uh kind of
debt-like insurance and so when you
start to think about that like what are
they holding they have to be losing
money on it there's i don't know of any
credible
debt that you can buy or bond that is
producing more than a five percent
return
right so you're you're just losing on a
real rate basis and the pension funds
have 50 percent of their assets there
so on the topic of bitcoin not you know
i'm sure i'm going to ask you this later
too off air so i might as well ask you
now but so
you know the unknown right
do
do you ever think about the unknown as
it pertains to bitcoin you know like
what if you say bitcoin risk you know
blah blah blah and i promise i'm not
trying to spread fud but i'm just saying
what are your questions let's just go
right through all your bitcoin questions
i mean
i don't know do you ever think about the
unknown
unknown in terms of unknown person who
created it unknown uh what's to happen
in the future
i mean if you said to me right now let's
do we'll do first the bear case for
bitcoin then we'll talk about the bull
case the bear case for bitcoin would be
uh
it's a global store of value today it's
obvious that people have adopted it's
grown into a trillion-dollar asset but
uh unlike what the bitcoin proponents
believe bitcoin won't cross over into
becoming a currency and therefore that
will drastically hamper kind of the
addressable market the most it could
grow to is gold which is basically a
store of value isn't really used for uh
to go purchase things on a day-to-day
basis and therefore yes there may be
more upside but it's kind of a capped
upside okay that would be one uh
critique of bitcoin that people can make
the second one is uh eventually we're to
figure out who satoshi is and if we
figure out who satoshi is that's going
to be a bad person and we're not going
to want to know who it is and like
there's going to be negative
impact again
maybe but
unlikely
the next thing is nobody's using it for
uh specific use cases like uh being able
to actually do cross-border payments all
stuff it's slow it's expensive it's kind
of all these like technical issues with
it
and then there's an argument of uh the
unknown of like the government's going
to clamp down on the future yeah i don't
think they can show that they're going
to regulate it they're going to tax it
they're going to shut it down they're
going to outlaw it they're going to do
all this stuff if you take every single
one of those things
none of them are a zero percent chance
but what is the odd two percent on each
of those
right each thing has one two percent
chance
and so okay and i'm not even talking
about those i'm just
you know maybe it's totally uneducated
it's just
one thing that gives me a little bit of
trepidation is i trust elon musk a lot
and
you look at his conviction around
bitcoin versus dorsey and it it just it
makes you think you know
what are his thoughts on i mean i know
he don't he owns a lot though right
from what i understand it's a material
part of his net worth personally on top
of something maybe basically maybe he's
look maybe he's
you know
i think i think the
best argument somebody could make and
what i think is the biggest risk to
bitcoin
it really pisses the critics off because
it has nothing to do with anything
external
there's still a development process
there is still a upgrade process to
bitcoin
and it's incredibly methodical it's
incredibly intentional it's slow on
purpose lots of kind of filters and
security checks et cetera
but technically a co uh there could be a
bug in the code that's introduced yeah
and so i guess like shooting yourself in
the foot right could that happen or i
mean anything i mean literally you know
and though electricity in the world
could shut off because uh meteor hit the
earth but if you think about it the
governments can't shut it down
you can't have nuclear war shut it down
right i mean i guess i mean you have to
have nuclear bombs all across the world
and even then you probably still
wouldn't announce there's still going to
be one computer somewhere that is
running that software it's kind of like
elon last night somebody was saying like
oh should the government shut it down or
i don't know and he's like he's like
they can't or something what did he say
yeah we were talking about it um
he basically said that they can't they
they can't kill bitcoin yeah right the
piece that i think most people forget
about all of this is when you have an
asset that isn't going to get shut down
the game theory takes over so let's say
that uh there's uh
four of us in a room you say i'm not
going to buy any and neither is anybody
else so you're in the camp if nobody
adopts it john is in the camp of saying
uh i'm not going to adopt it but
somebody else is joe's in the camp if
i'm going to adopt it and nobody else is
and i'm in the camp of i'm going to buy
and so is everybody else right if you
kind of think of a kind of a four or two
by two grid as like a game theory if
nobody adopts it like you nothing
changes in the world
if you're in john's seat you don't adopt
it and everyone else adopts it you're
last
right to adopt it that ends up being a
really bad
situation both from a security
standpoint and also a financial
standpoint if you're in joe's position
which is he adopts it nobody else adopts
it then you end up being way ahead of
everybody else but it almost doesn't
matter because the value of the market
is determined by
is there demand for an asset right
that's true of every asset since the
beginning of time so actually
everyone is financially incentivized to
do
what
to participate
but it's also driven by everyone else
participating and that's where you get
value in an asset so from a game theory
standpoint you get hurt by not
participating and
you don't necessarily get hurt if you
participate and
others don't
but the trend is everyone's
participating right so it's like that
was the kind of game theory in 2009
2010. now there's no question are other
people going to do this
so the game theory takes over it's like
yeah you should participate and again it
could be
0.1 of your entire net worth right it
doesn't mean you got to go do a lot or
whatever but the game theory is really
strong here yeah and
you know to be clear i don't i own a lot
like because it
because in dollars it makes me think
like wow i own a lot of bitcoin like i
should really make sure i know what the
hell's going on with this thing and i
think i've done the due diligence but i
own a little over 10 which is not a lot
in terms of when you i mean you own like
what 95 of your net worth in the damn
thing yeah i mean so so when i asked the
question about the unknown unknown and
you know your mind could go a zillion
different directions it just how do you
get the confidence to go from 10 percent
to
95
your 10
is in the new digital financial system
yep
you're 90 in the legacy financial system
couldn't they say that about ethereum
though
it could be what you buy whatever asset
you want right and guess what the
market's going to determine who wins and
loses i'm most comfortable with and i
have the most confidence in bitcoin
because here's the other thing that i
think happens in the crypto world that
uh people misunderstand is i think of uh
the risk
spectrum in let's call the crypto
industry
on the far left you have the least risky
asset bitcoin it is kind of the uh the
the blue chip largest most decentralized
longest track record etc a thousand
percent in crypto least risky most
conservative asset on the other end of
the spectrum you have
crazy things that people are coming up
with all kinds of tokens and
schemes and innovations and and
experiments and whatever that you can go
buy for a penny right so you have on one
end super conservative on the other end
you have super risky
when you look at the crypto industry
what most people are doing is they come
into the industry and the people who end
up going way out on the risk curve they
literally say oh yeah of course bitcoin
is going to work
but i want better returns than bitcoin
they're chasing something that is higher
or better performing than bitcoin alone
and so what
i think about is the reason why bitcoin
is so attractive is i actually don't
need to have the best returning assets i
don't need to be greedy
i want the thing that has a great
economic return
but also i know it's gonna be around in
50 years so let me ask you do you have
anxiety about not putting the rest of
your five percent in bitcoin no because
a lot of that ends up being uh and when
i use percentage is usually liquid net
worth i've got cash
and then uh i still make some private
investments as well so in some crazy way
like if i invest in a company that then
uh is using the lightning network like
it's not bitcoin exposure but you know
that's pretty close it's uh it's
definitely related the other piece of it
by the way tell me if we're going off
topic too no that was perfect uh i mean
i'll talk about bitcoin all day long
yeah uh so will they um well i think
there's a lot of questions a lot of
people have if you're like the bitcoin
guy i mean if you want to know about
housing i'll tell you about it all day
long
if you compare
what i just talked about in the crypto
world of like conservative on one end
super risky on the other end of the
crypto industry
if you look at the regular financial
world like the legacy financial world
bitcoin is the most risky asset you
could buy
right and then like maybe bonds or cash
or something is unlike the other end and
so the beauty of sitting in like that
bitcoin
seat
is that all of the crypto guys and girls
who are like way out on the wrist curve
they're like this is like the most like
what are you doing right like that's not
going to drive you great returns yeah
they call you a boomer yeah yeah
but the legacy finance world like i go
talk to you know big hedge funds right
they're like what are you doing like
that is the craziest thing i've ever
heard yeah that's actually probably
where you want to be i agree right like
i know there's way crazier things that
you could do in the world
but i also know that there's way safer
things you could do in the world so like
but 95 is very respectable you don't say
that that often do you i mean i hear you
say it once in a while yeah i mean it's
uh
it sounds like a crazy number until you
just say no i just denominate my life
and my portfolio in bitcoin so it's no
different than dollars right if you have
uh a hundred percent most people right
in dollars in dollar denominated bonds
or dollar denominated assets you
essentially have 100 exposure to what i
think of as the legacy financial world
and so
if you ask me right now gun to my head
which financial world has the most room
to grow moving forward well the legacy
world is like we've had it for you know
100 plus years right like it's been here
there's just not that much future growth
to it
versus we get this crazy stuff and it's
why like the stock market was freaking
out over two percent drop right i mean
literally right now bitcoin could drop
five percent and no one would even
care it's just like yeah of course it
goes up and down you know three five ten
percent a day are you surprised it's not
higher now
i don't know if i'm necessarily
surprised it's not higher
um hindsight bias is real strong because
you kind of understand why it's not
higher uh
but i would be very surprised if it
doesn't go much higher through the end
of this year like if we didn't at least
get a new all-time high something
happened that uh i either didn't
understand didn't foresee uh or um
uh
just missed right all-time high is only
20k away it's like a 50 move from here
which again sounds crazy in legacy terms
in bitcoin crypto world like you know
that's like could happen in a week um
and then on top of that it's like once
it breaks through the all-time high like
where does it go
i mean we've had how many people come on
and you hear everything from 80
to somebody recently said 400 000 this
year like yeah and and they all have a
good explanation and you're like yeah
all
80 to 400 000 is all possible right it's
funny so we'll see how do you think
about uh buying uh stocks versus like
more bitcoin or anything that's like
more like alternative investor private
markets well i've been thinking about
upping my percent of bitcoin uh
so i've recently gone over that 10
percent amount and it's growing because
it's getting
bigger you know but
um do you rebalance that's another thing
that i see a lot of institutions love to
rebalance
but in some weird way you're basically
taking your best performers and you're
cutting your exposure
versus
just
make the investments and then just let
them turn into whatever they do yeah not
really i mean in the early days i was
selling a little bit of bitcoin but that
was because uh it just went up so quick
that you were just like what the you
know what is going on here you know and
i always get worried about the
psychological phenomena of like
confirmation bias and it's like okay
like yeah i think it's going up because
i know why it's going up but do i really
know why it's going up and it keeps just
going you know so
so no i don't really imagine being one
of these guys that has a billion dollars
of it or you know five billion dollars
of it and it keeps going up right it's
since you must think you're a genius
it gets pretty crazy right i mean joe
and john is uh the best story i think
we've told on this on
the show before is joe uh called me one
day and uh john had bought bitcoin i
don't know whatever it was and he goes
you got to talk to john and i was like
why and he's like john said he ain't
going to make it to 20k is that like 11.
and i was like what do you mean he goes
yeah he said dude this thing goes to 20
i'm selling and now what percent of your
guys money do you have in it a very
similar amount
95 yeah how about you uh yeah i'm
probably in the i got to do some
calculations but i'm probably in like
the 90s
i hope i don't buy more today but but
here's here but here's what we have to
remember is it's also different when
you're younger when like yeah but i'm 33
right and i see it and i see bitcoin as
play you know as plain as day right yeah
i don't understand people who don't see
it
but i think that's the light bulb right
is like once you realize that and you
you think of it in the context of like
it's inevitable right to some degree uh
you start aggressively figuring out how
you can acquire more right and knowing
that it's constraint supply all you're
looking at is the demand
it becomes a no-brainer you want to hear
a story i never told anybody
in 2018 i took uh 50
of uh basically my net worth my
portfolio whatever you want to say and i
put in bitcoin and it happened to be
near the bottom of the bear market in
2018
uh in december i think the bottom was
like december 14th or whatever
and
i remember walking around because
bitcoin had been it had gone from 20 to
6 500 and there's like this like puked
down i remember walking around new york
city
and just like thinking to myself like
you're either insane or like you know
something that they all don't see or
know or whatever
i had been paying attention to it for
you know a number of years whatever at
that point would be two three years
whatever it was and
i remember saying to myself this is
likely
what
the housing short trade
the
com bus like like all these different
things is
it's a combination not only of the
information that you have been able to
spend time and learn and do all that but
also the way that you evaluate it the
way that you analyze and understand or
at least think you understand how it's
going to play out or whatever
and at some point you just got to say to
yourself like you just trust yourself
right at least for me and and so
i was just like all right screw it and i
knew that the reason why i did 50 was
because i was willing to lose that
right i was like look at at that point i
was you know i don't know so would you
be willing to lose to 95 yeah now yeah
which is why i'm comfortable doing that
right but
it's because i've got high earning
potential i'm still young like i could
recover
if i was 45 or 50 i wouldn't do it
it's all about like
i think a lot about um there's a book
richer wiser happier i think it's the
name of it by william green and he
basically goes out and he interviews
like the top 25 investors he can find
and so he has this guy pab bry who's
like famous for just emulating warren
buffett he has um nick sleep he's got a
bunch of these guys that he goes and he
talks to he's basically like what are
you doing i even interviews charlie
munger for the book or whatever
and there's two key things that i
learned in that book that surprised me
one majority of the best investors in
the world
high high high concentration in their
portfolio it's like charlie munger only
owns three stocks yeah right it's like
berkshire hathaway costco and i forget
what the third one is and you're like
wait what like
now berkshire owns a bunch of different
you know businesses whatever but like he
only owns three stocks i think so what
do you think the chances are though if
you're investing in those three
companies and having
enough
knowledge to beat the s p
i think that's kind of like table sticks
at this point right is um if you go back
to uh somebody was telling me this
recently so uh bear with me if the stats
aren't exactly right but if you go back
and you look at all the icos from 2017
right
and you look at them today the scams the
like all the things that literally and i
was one of the biggest people saying
like hey i'm not investing any of this
this is all nonsense to me
it's up like 300
today
and so you're like literally things that
i personally believe have no value yeah
right that like a lot of people were
pointing at being like this is literally
a scam it's still up a ton and the
reason why that ends up happening is
it's not because it's valuable it's
because you're betting on an industry
that ends up growing so significantly
and so you're betting on something
that's small and ends up growing up and
so when you think of it that way like
why would you
end up actually investing in the legacy
market like you could be what what was
the hamster that's beating the smp mr mr
doc did you hear about this yeah
right yeah mr knox he's like gosh
capital yeah
he's running around he's got a hamster
he's running around he's beating the s p
why he's literally doing it with assets
that are going up significantly more
than the smp yeah
right there with the bitcoin
now you'll have to go buy more bitcoin
now we're in business no but seriously
the reason that i take it so seriously
is not just because of my own family and
and you know trying to provide for my
family with money but if i can figure
out how to compound to our point earlier
returns over a period of time
you know my capital i look at it is
helping fuel a lot of this transaction
volume that's going across twitter for
the poverty angle so
it's it's a very helpful discussion i
completely agree before we uh moved to
wrap up here
i have one question and then if we get
to 5k likes joe's giving away a thousand
bucks don't think we didn't do we didn't
hit 5k yet all right bill we're close
what do you think bitcoin's price goes
to this year in 2021 well
i'll give you that but i think that it's
going to be a million dollars a coin
okay not this year necessarily maybe not
this cycle but i think pretty soon it
will be um
i think that
uh if if we get another momentum in the
market it's just my opinion and you know
these things they trade with momentum
you know even like mstr stock it trades
with momentum if we get an upward
momentum and let's say that there's
continues to be this high inflation
print
you know
there's no ceiling to where it could go
but i would say you know 75
i think it'll at least be at 75.
so new all-time high this year yeah and
then you think that at some point the
next couple of years a million dollars i
think probably mid next year i think
that it will get it will get harder
uh
just the growth in the economy i think
will be harder on stuff and i do think
bitcoin and we may disagree on this i do
think bitcoin at least from what i've
seen
tends to trade like a commodity from
what i've seen
um
and i've been a little disappointed with
it the last couple weeks at how uh you
know how how much it traded even with
the market but i guess that's you know
that's it's probably nothing compared to
what it used to be right
it happens it tends to be a
non-correlated asset but there are
periods where it gets high correlation
and a lot of it's the macro stuff where
people just start saying hey there's a
risk asset or whatever and also it used
to be a much different audience that
held bitcoin as you get into now more
financially savvy folks with it then
you're gonna have them trade it like
it's another stock or another commodity
in their portfolio versus historically
those people who they didn't care about
the financials and again this is out of
my circle of competency so i don't
really know it but you know you ask so
that's what i think what are you
giggling about nothing
i think we're going over 100 this year
you think we're going over 100k yeah
yeah what is the math behind that yeah
young wizard will clemente
you know what else it just went over
it was one over 5000 likes so get your
checkbook out if it goes over if it goes
over
a hundred thousand i'll come back and
give more money away there we go you
might be back in like a couple of weeks
what uh is this i guess i gotta buy more
bills it's going towards the end of the
year like a make or break like is this
make a break for bitcoin or
say it sits at 40 for the rest of the
year bitcoin could drop to 3 000
and i would literally sell the shirt off
your back to get more money to go buy it
that's the other thing too is like when
when bill was talking earlier about if
you're comfortable losing the amount of
money the 95 or whatever
at the end of the day uh it's never
gonna go to zero because there's so many
there's so many people who have such a
strong conviction in it that would never
sell right like you're never going to
sell it so it's not it's never gonna
you're lowering that risk reward profile
right on the wrist side and then if it
dips down to that number wherever it
ends up being like you would just
aggressively buy as much as you could
knowing that there's only ever going to
be 21 million the demand is still super
strong if bitcoin dropped to 3 000
michael saylor and president buchelli
would have to fight me to see who could
buy the bitcoin at 3k okay like so would
everybody else what about like 18 000
like why 3 000. just whatever it is
it dropped to 30 000. i bought a bunch
more right and it wasn't because i was
like oh any other reason then like i
just periodically buy more as i make
more money uh which keeps them like 95
but also
uh
when it dips i have such long-term
conviction like the other piece of this
too is like there's people who trade it
right so they want to buy it today
they're going to sell tomorrow you'll
buy it today they're going to sell it in
a week or whatever that's not me yeah i
literally just say as i buy it i have a
number in my head okay now i got more
now i got more and i just said look i'm
going to hand to my grandkids and i
think that psychologically like when i
decided that so what does your bride
think about you owning 95 she sold the
reason why there's five percent uh not
in bitcoin it's worked out so far
that was our agreement was uh there had
to be a certain amount of money that was
in the bank account where it was like
all right we're like we're good uh for a
period of time and then you could do you
know whatever you want and i talked to
her about it but i think uh
there's been two times where
it was dropping aggressively and i had
like bought like uh i told sorry of uh
in march 2020 it went from like 8 000 to
4 000 in a single day or like 3 800 and
that morning i wrote a piece and
published it like i took the time out of
my day wrote a piece and said we're in a
liquidity crisis asset prices are
selling off they're likely to sell off
more so i went from eight to six i
bought a bunch then went from six to
like 5 500 i bought you know uh a little
bit more and then i think it like got
down to like 4 800 and i remember saying
to myself like am i gonna watch this go
to zero like i was literally sitting on
the couch like staring off in space and
for whatever you know it's coming like
whatever just psychologically like it
just sucks
and she looked at me she's like what's
wrong and i was like bitcoin might go to
zero like i might just like watch this
blow up and she said to me she was like
what are you doing buy more she's like
like if it's going down like just like
go down with the ship yeah and so i you
know uh very reluctantly bought a little
bit more and i remember saying to myself
like there's almost this beauty in not
being involved in it every day because
she was just like i don't think she
computed like the price had dropped 50
percent and all this stuff she's just
like what do you believe do you ever
have days where you don't check the
price
i rarely check the price actually good
for you uh the only times i check the
price are uh one people like to tweet it
at me so i happen to see it then uh or
two is uh when i read like a news
article and what i'm very interested in
now is like when china reiterated this
ban last week um
bitcoin's only down like four five
percent i would have thought if you told
me hey they're going to do it again like
all right here we go down you know 10 12
percent and so it looks like the mark is
becoming less sensitive to certain
narratives that's great it's bullish
yeah but if you know certain people went
out and tweeted today in the united
states and said something you know they
could tank at 10 15 you know overnight
so you just kind of pay attention to it
and try to figure it out there i check
the price all the time
and it's a problem because even if it
goes up i'm not going to sell any so
it's just like i'm just making myself
worried and then when it goes there's a
deal yeah
so i feel like that'll wear off after
time but it's still fun yeah it's still
fun there's no need one day john walked
in here and he's like hey man what's
going on with bitcoin i was like what do
you mean he's like you need to like call
somebody or something this thing's got
to start going back up he's like i'm not
into this whole thing of like bitcoin
going down in price i was like what and
he was like yeah it was down whatever
the price was and i said what do you
want to do he's like look i like to buy
assets that go up and down
that's funny i was like all right all
right what are we uh what are we giving
away or uh how are you gonna do this
we're giving away a thousand dollars
well you're giving away you're giving
away this well y'all are just so we're
all clear like you yes
it's my turn yes yes to give away all
right how do you want to do this uh
you can well you had all this time to
think about it you don't even have an
idea what i think we should do is uh
so to
qualify you have to be subscribed to the
channel
i'm gonna check
and then comment on the video and just
say that you subscribed wait in the chat
in the chat comment in the chat and say
subscribed you have to be subscribed to
the channel and i'll pick one person for
a thousand dollars okay so you got to be
subscribed to the channel then you got a
comment saying i subscribed or submitted
just subscribe yeah
once you're done subscribing right so
how are you going to pick how how is
somebody going to stand out but everyone
just writes the word subscribed i'm
going to pick just randomly yeah like
whoever's username you like just
randomly all
right well
give people a second to subscribe
subscribe to the channel and comment and
don't be lying
i thought you were going to check that's
what i'm saying bill i really like that
you were talking about how like you know
they're talking you know there's
scammers out there that when you give
away money and stuff they're hey i have
this problem or whatever that's my
situation um but you're okay with that
because of the good you do on the kind
of like the actual people that get
exactly yeah that's exactly how i think
about it you know
some people lose their minds over the
fact that i give out money and say how
do you know you didn't you know get this
person's social security number and you
didn't
you know figure out where they live
forget that yeah yeah i like that help
90 of people to win
all right joe you ready
let's give it a minute people are still
subscribing
remember we talked about cool valley uh
remember the missouri
it just came out that he has funded the
project he's gonna give a thousand
dollars in bitcoin to every single
household i wonder who gave him the
money yeah i don't know um his name is
uh mayor jason stewart and his uh his
twitter bios all the time it just says
small town mayor
[Laughter]
pretty cool we'll talk about that more
tomorrow but all right what do you got
for us all right i'm ready
uh the winner is
anna rivas
a a
revos i will tag you in the chat right
now nice
good guy joe
dm joe on twitter on a dm me on twitter
you'll get your
thousand dollars in
uh could be cash bitcoin we'll talk but
dm me on uh on twitter anna
rivas all right
bill did you enjoy this i did thanks for
having me guys bill thank you appreciate
you appreciate it congratulations on
building something cool uh well we
appreciate you building something cool
um
where can we send people to find out
more twitter philanthropy teamgiving.com
teamgiving.com that's the big
philanthropy or that's the big 501c3
that we've set up where people
with legitimate needs can go
and it will be vetted by an experienced
team so we haven't figured out the
decentralized way yet but just given the
demand we didn't want to just rely on
gofundme so it's been a great
a great thing working with the team at
team giving and you know
just if you see somebody and your heart
tells you to donate
great if not it's all good
all right i just put the link in there a
couple of times because the chat is
going pretty nuts right now so uh
hopefully you guys got that and go check
out teamgiving.com uh hey geniuses what
what uh final comments do you have joe
is your collar popped right now no it's
a it's like a special dude what are you
talking about
where are your other two brothers yeah
like uh they're in new york and new
jersey one's a doctor so he like has
like a real job and he's not allowed to
screw in on the internet uh and then we
have another brother who uh works at a
wall street firm and we try he was down
here actually we tried to get him to uh
come on the show and he was like do you
want me to get fired i'm like yes
does he get a lot of [ __ ] for it in new
york or no
no i don't think so you guys are
becoming like an internet meme
yeah
he uh he did recently i don't want to
call it who it is but he introduced me
to somebody he texted me he goes hey so
and so wants to talk about uh like these
bitcoin minor companies what they're
looking at can you do me a favor and
talk to them
so i thought it was like
somebody that he met like getting drinks
or something you know like a friend yeah
and uh it turns out it's a former
colleague that now works like a big
hedge fund or whatever and i got on and
and uh they couldn't have been nicer but
they are like questions like so what
questions would you ask the ceo of a
bitcoin mining company i was like well i
didn't realize i would bring my due
diligence
so i said vince you got to uh you got to
chill out there with that um all right
you guys got any last comments before we
get out of here no appreciate you coming
on bill thank you for doing uh great
work thank you john pay off your credit
card
make sure that's all he ever says at the
end of the show because i don't like
people having um 20 interest loans that
kind of puts them behind the starting
line yeah that should be criminal yeah
so pay off your credit card hopefully
hopefully bitcoin will solve that yep
true all right we appreciate all of you
watching huge show today uh i don't know
what we're going to do tomorrow to uh to
deliver
maybe joe will take his shirt off or
something all right we'll see you guys
tomorrow thanks
[Music]
foreign